[Musique]
Thba de Monbrial. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement et quels sont vos domaines
d'intérêt, vos centres d'activité ?
J'ai 50 ans, je suis avocat au barreau
de Paris. Je dirige un cabinet qui
s'appelle MI2 avocat et qui s'occupe de
dossiers pénaux. s'occupe de pénal des
affaires pour les chefs d'entreprise et
aussi un gros engagement personnel
auprès des forces de sécurité
intérieure, les questions de légitime
défense, les victimes de crimes et
notamment de de terrorisme et enfin le
droit de la liberté d'expression,
c'est-à-dire la diffamation. Donc ça
c'est le cabinet d'avocat. Et à côté de
ça, euh je suis président du centre de
réflexion sur la sécurité intérieure et
euh je dirige donc ce petit think tank
qui est dédié comme son nom l'indique
aux questions de sécurité intérieure qui
sont des questions que que je que je
connais bien et sur lesquelles je
travaille avec un certain nombre de gens
au sein de l'appareil d'État et je
conseille des femmes et des hommes
politiques et c'est un on va bien sûr en
parler mais c'est un engagement au-delà
de ma vie strictement professionnelle
que j'ai pris dans dans les années 2012-
2013 quand j'ai compris ce qui était en
train d'arriver à notre pays, je peux
pas me résoudre simplement à être avocat
et spectateur de ce qui est en train
d'arriver. Et donc, j'ai décidé de de
m'engager par les connaissances que j'ai
sur ces questions mais qui sont des
connaissances qui ne sont pas simplement
des connaissances neutres mais qui sont
des connaissances engagées.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui est en train de
d'arriver à notre pays ? Quel est votre
constat sur la sécurité au sein de notre
propre territoire ? Alors le
en commençant par le les constats les
plus récents, c'est que euh on est un
petit peu comme dans un dessin animé euh
vous savez où on voit ces petits
personnages qui courent et le sol qui se
craquelle sous leur pas et il y a un
moment où le sol s'effondre et il
continue à courir un petit peu avant de
tomber dans le vide. On est quelque part
entre le moment où le sol qui a déjà
commencé à se craquer est en train de se
craqueler de partout et le moment où ça
commence à tomber. On est on est quelque
part par là que vous regardez tous les
problèmes toutes les problématiques de
sécurité euh le le le terrorisme
islamiste bien sûr, mais également euh
les extrêmes euh que vous regardez euh
la la dureté des rapports sociaux euh
qui monte de partout, euh des euh un
respect de moins en moins important
envers tout ce qui est institutionnel.
Euh et quand on va jusqu'au mouvement
qui est en train de se densifier autour
de la colère, autour du du prix de
l'essence qui qui monte parce que ça
n'est évidemment pas de la violence
directe mais c'est euh du de de la
remise en cause et du et du rejet des
institutions. Quel que soit le bout par
lequel on le prend, on se rend compte
que notre pays affronte une violence de
plus en plus grande. Sur le terrain, les
forces de sécurité intérieure sont
devenues aujourd'hui des cibles. C'estàd
que l'hypothèse de la mort du policier
ou du gendarme est une hypothèse qui est
complètement acceptée par les gens qui
sont en face. qu'il s'agisse euh de
d'islamistes évidemment, mais qu'il
s'agisse aussi de manifestants et
notamment de de manifestants d'extrême
gauche. Donc, on a cette logique euh où
l'uniforme n'est plus respectée. Le
l'uniforme est considérée comme une
bande rivale où les policiers et les
gendarmes sont même traqués dans leur
vie privée puisque on a depuis le
printemps au CRSI, on a recensé cette
agressions de de policiers hors service,
mais on ne prétend pas à l'exhaustivité,
il y en a peut-être eu plus. Donc ça
c'est le constat, si vous voulez
immédiat. Si on prend un petit peu de
champ et la raison pour laquelle je me
suis engagé euh publiquement sur ces
questions de sécurité, c'est que euh au
tournant des années 2010 euh je vous
disais 12 13 euh la France a commencé à
euh percevoir de le grand public a
commencé à percevoir quelque chose que
que les que les professionnels
percevaient depuis un moment, c'est que
les déséquilibres
au sein de sur notre territoire, au sein
de notre population, les déséquilibres
induits par un certain nombre de
décisions politique notamment au regard
de l'immigration depuis une quarantaine
d'années commençait à avoir des
conséquences directes et pour moi la
bascule c'est le fait que avec les
événements en Syrie depuis la fin 2011
de plus en plus de jeunes occidentaux et
donc de jeunes français donc nés en
France sont partis pour faire le djihad
avec une conséquence directe qui qu'il
était très facile d'anticiper si on
s'intéresse un peu d'un peu près à ces
questions, c'est qu'à partir du moment
où une fraction d'une population qui
était déjà dans la détestation de notre
pays, bien qu'en étant issu au moins
juridiquement, allait se former pour
aller faire la guerre, il était
inévitable que cette guerre serait tôt
ou tard réimportée dans notre pays, soit
directement par le retour de ces gens,
soit par la projection que ces gens
depuis le théâtre syriakin allaient
organiser de leur guerre sur le
territoire occidental. Et évidemment, ça
n'a pas manqué de se produire. Alors, on
entend beaucoup de de journalistes, de
personnes dire "On a plus de chance de
se faire foudroyer que de mourir dans un
attentat terroriste". Qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez leur répondre ? Alors euh
foudroyez peut-être pas ce qu'on entend
en général, c'est plus de chance de ou
de risque de mourir dans un accident de
voiture. Euh alors c'est statistiquement
vrai. Euh sauf que euh les conséquences
les les conséquences euh pour pour le
pour notre société de l'accident de
voiture n'ont absolument rien à voir
avec les conséquences du terrorisme.
Conséquences économique, conséquences de
stress, conséquences de peur.
Oui. Et puis et et conséquences et
conséquences politiques. Quel est
qu'est-ce que c'est que le terrorisme ?
Il y a on a eu pendant la définition du
du dictionnaire c'est quoi ? C'est
alors il y a il y a 1000 définitions. Il
y a la définition du code pénal, les
définitions du dictionnaires, il y a les
définitions des par exemple si vous
prenez la définition des Israéliens et
des Palestiniens, ça va pas être la
même. Donc la définition du terrorisme,
elle est elle est elle est multiple.
Mais pour faire simple, c'est un c'est
un acte qui vise à impressionner au sens
fort du mot, c'est-à-dire à créer une
impression. l'impression étant la
terreur sur une population pour
entraîner des changements politiques. Et
c'est là où je veux en venir. Et la
France a euh pendant 5 ans subi euh un
président de la République qui a refusé
de nommer ce qu'il faut bien appeler
l'ennemi puisque ce sont des gens qui
nous ont désignés comme leur ennemi.
C'est pas nous qui les désignons comme
ennemis, c'est l'ennemi qui vous
désigne. Et François Hollande pendant 4
ans très exactement a refusé d'acoller
au mot terrorisme l'adjectif islamiste.
Le terrorisme en soi, ça n'est rien.
C'est un concept. Le terrorisme en
réalité, c'est un moyen d'action
politique. Et cette politique, c'est une
politique de conquête qui est menée par
des gens qui sont des islamistes. Donc
c'est un une action politique. Il y a
1000 manières d'agir politiquement. La
violence est l'une d'elles. Ça n'est pas
la seule. Les islamistes d'ailleurs ne
ne se cantonnent pas du tout loin sans
faut à la violence terroriste. Mais pour
en revenir à votre question, pourquoi
est-ce que c'est si important ? parce
que contrairement au au au fait
individuel qui est l'accident de
voiture, même s'il a des conséquences
sur la sécurité sociale et cetera, mais
le le le terrorisme islamiste est
l'expression d'une volonté de rupture au
sein de notre de de notre pays, mais
même au sein de notre mode de vie et et
au sein de de l'Europe et de l'Occident
en tout entier. Donc nous nous serions
fous de ne pas le comprendre alors que
nos ennemis nous le répètent à à à à
longueur de de de communiqué,
d'expression sur les réseaux sociaux et
cetera et cetera. L'ennemi nous a
désigné et nous sommes dans une lutte
qui est une lutte politique. Et souvent
on dit et c'est d'ailleurs le ce qui est
sous sous-jacent dans la question que
que vous que vous me posez. En tout cas,
dans ce que vous rapportez de ce que
beaucoup de gens disent, on dit "Oui,
mais c'est c'est tragique pour ceux qui
sont touchés, mais comment pouvez-vous
imaginer qu'un pays aussi structuré que
que la France ou que que ou que l'Union
européenne puisse
réellement être en danger face à des
gens qui sont très peu nombreux et
cetera et cetera
À cet argument, je je dirais il faut il
faut être capable de concevoir les
choses en dehors du du périmètre
habituel de la pensée. Euh on vit une
attaque non conventionnelle de type ring
sur un barrage, sur un nœud internet,
sur une centrale électrique.
Avant même de rentrer sur les scénarios
de de rupture directe qui pourraient
nous impacter et ils existent, vous en
avez rappelé quelques-uns, il y en a
d'autres. Il faut il faut bien voir que
ça fait 70 ans que l'Europe de l'Ouest,
l'Europe occidentale vit en paix. Il y a
eu la guerre des Balcans dans les années
90, mais pour tout ce qui constitue le
le cœur de l'Union européenne, nous
sommes en paix de depuis en gros 70 ans.
Et donc nous avons nous nous
collectivement dans et y compris
maintenant dans notre ADN,
on a on a oublié ce que c'était que que
que la violence physique et que la
guerre sur notre territoire et toutes
nos élites. Voyez, par exemple,
c'est pour ça que vous vous reprochez au
magistrat d'être passif, d'être trop
clément. pas que pas que pas que au
magistrats, je je reproche les
magistrats. Je pense je pense qu'il y a
un problème d'autorité et et et
d'habitude dans la magistrature. Il y a
des habitudes. On on on traite les
dossiers sans se rendre compte de
l'évolution de de la big picture comme
disent les angloaxons qui est en train
d'évoluer. On y reviendra après si vous
voulez mais ce que je voulais dire c'est
que là on a oublié que que la violence
et que la guerre c'était pas que à la
télé. Et en fait, c'est une sorte de
péché d'orgueil parce que on considère
que euh nous sommes euh le le pays des
droits de l'homme, que nous sommes
formidable et l'Union européenne aurait
une sorte de de de supériorité morale
sur le reste du monde qui qui en quelque
sorte la protégerait parce que nous
serions euh nous nous serions les les
gentils et nous allons d'ailleurs
évangéliser les uns et les autres sans
tenir compte de leur mode de vie, de
leur culture, de leur histoire et du
coup en créant des déséquilibres
terribles qui nous reviennent en pleine
figure.
Et donc il ne peut rien nous arriver
parce que nous sommes les gentils. Mais
c'est une vision qui qui est d'une
grande naïveté. Et juste pour finir, nos
politiques au sens large, nos nos femmes
et nos hommes politiques, nos
dirigeants, nos nos leaders des grands
médias, nos leaders économiques ont
encore beaucoup de mal, moins qu'il y a
3 ans, c'est vrai, mais ont encore
beaucoup de mo à concevoir l'ampleur de
du risque que fait peser la la la
conquête islamiste sur l'Europe.
C'est un péché d'orgueil ou c'est un
péché d'impuissance ? Parce que je je me
refuse de croire que on va prendre
l'exemple de François Hollande qu'il ne
reçoit pas qu'il ne recevait pas sur son
petit bureau des notes des différents
services, des notes de terrain du
renseignement brut ou des choses comme
ça. C'est un péché d'impuissance dans le
sens où s'attaquer à ce problème à ce
problème-là
remettrait en cause notre politique
étrangère, notre politique extérieure,
notre capacité à déstabiliser des pays
qui sont pas du tout fait pour être
déstabilisés ou qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Moi, il y a une chose qui m'a beaucoup
frappé. Euh en février 2015, il y a une
vidéo terrible de l'État islamique qui
est mise en ligne. Il y en a eu
beaucoup, mais celle-là elle et vous
allez voir pourquoi j'en parle, parce
que je vais finir avec le commentaire
que François Hollande en a fait. 21
chrétiens coopt égyptiens sont enlevés
en Égypte et ils sont placé sur une
plage en Libye. Euh c'est filmé depuis
euh la depuis la la berge et derrière on
voit la mer. Donc a la scénarisation
avec l'État islamique a toujours été
très importante.
Voilà. Pardon. C'est là où il y a le
gamin.
Non, il y a pas de gamin. Il y a 21 Il y
a 21 coptes. Ils sont en uniforme orange
puisqueil y avait donc cette cette ce
graphisme ces ces visuels de l'État
islamique qui a utilisé toutes les
techniques de l'infotainment pour
en référence à Guantanamo.
En référence à Guantanamo. Et les 21
coptes les 21 sont suppliciers et sont
égorgés au couteau. Et à la fin de la
vidéo,
donc il y a la mer méditerranée derrière
et à la fin de la vidéo, il y a il y a
un des bourreaux qui s'approche avec son
couteau. Il s'approche de la caméra et
il dit "Vous nous avez connu sur les
collines syriennes, nous sommes au sud
de Rome, nous arrivons avec évidemment
la Libye qui est en face de l'Italie et
cetera et cetera."
Donc émotion internationale et
commentaire de de de François Hollande
euh qui euh s'inscrit qui s'érige contre
euh le le supplice des citoyens
égyptiens. Il les appelle les citoyens
égyptiens. Alors c'est juridiquement
vrai, c'était des citoyens égyptiens.
Mais ce qui est important là, c'est que
c'était des chrétiens cootes. C'était ça
qui était important. Ce qui est
important dans ce message, c'est que on
a un message de de symbolique
d'appel à la conquête de Rome,
c'est-à-dire de l'Occident. Rome, c'est
c'est symbolique. Et et avec en plus la
mer méditerranée qui est derrière, donc
à l'horizon, il y a Rome, à l'horizon,
il y a nous. Et le fait, le décalage
entre le commentaire sur cette vidéo et
la réalité de de ce qu'elle implique, il
était concernant. Vous dites que
François Hollande était très bien
entouré. Vous avez raison. François
Hollande avait au moins deux ministres
qui ont parfaitement compris ce qui se
passait et quels étaient les enjeux.
C'est Bernard Kisneu à l'intérieur et
Manuel Vals qui à l'époque euh était
était premier ministre. Et eux,
d'ailleurs Manuel Vals a fait un
discours que j'ai trouvé remarquable euh
le le 13 janvier le 13 janvier euh à
2015 à l'Assemblée après une semaine
après Charlie où il a nommé, il a dit
"Nous sommes en guerre, le terrorisme
islamiste islamiste islamiste et
cetera."
Mais c'était il y avait il y avait et du
coup les silences les les pudeurs de de
François Hollande n'en étaient que que
plus criantes. C'est d'autant plus
étrange mais ça va me permettre de
répondre à votre question. Pourquoi que
dans le bouquin de Dav et l'homme ce
qu'un prés
auteur dans le monde sur une enquête
faite par des élèves journalistes
syndicateur je parle de le bouquin de
Davélom pardon ce qu'un président ne
devrait pas dire il y a quelques années
où ils ont rencontré pendant des des des
semaines régulièrement le président et
ils font du off il y a du off sur 1000
pages. Bon
il a dit qu'il y avait des assassins qui
s'occupaient de faire le ménage. Alors
ouais, c'est pas ça que je voulais dire,
c'est il dit aussi ça, ce qui d'ailleurs
il aurait pas dû dire euh mais c'est
déjà bien que ça que ça se fasse. Euh
mais il dit il il parle du risque de
partition de notre pays à cause de de de
le de l'islam radical. Donc il a
conscience. Donc quand on quand on met
côte à côte ces deux ces deux constats,
ces deux ces deux déclarations de
Hollande, une sur la vidéo des du
supplice descopt et et l'autre c'est ses
propos à Dav et l'homme, on peut pas
dire qu' qu'il n'a pas compris puisqu'il
il dit en off qu'il l'a compris. Et à
mon sens la réponse et c'est encore vrai
aujourd'hui un peu moins qu'avant, on
l'a vu avec ce qu'a dit Gérard Colomb
récemment, mais c'est qu'il y a une
tétanie à nommer les choses.
Rappelez-nous ce qu'a dit Gérard Colomb.
Alors, Gérard Colomb euh a dit euh en en
septembre ou début octobre, au moment où
il a quitté son ministère, quand au le
au moment de la passation euh de pouvoir
entre lui et non pas son successeur,
parce qu'on est resté 15 jours sans
successeur, mais enfin euh Édouard
Philippe qui faisait fonction de euh il
a euh tenu euh pendant 5 minutes, ça
dure quand même 5 minutes, il s'est
lancé sur le perron de de de Bova dans
une expression de ses craintes
en rappelant toutes les que lui, il
recevait des notes tous les jours et
cetera et en parlant d'un certain nombre
de quartiers dont certains étaient
d'ailleurs nommés, mais enfin il en a
nommé trois sur plusieurs centaines, en
disant que c'était des quartiers où je
paraphrase et je résume, mais les
trafiquants et les islamistes avaient
pris la main que la République en était
quand même il était quand même de moins
en moins présente et il finit par cette
phrase qui là pour le coup est du
verbime. Il dit "Nous nous avons vécu
côte à côte et je crains que ça ne se
finisse face- à face."
ce qui enfin le mec est quand même
ministre de l'intérieur. Donc là, il
fait une déclaration où il dit tout haut
ce que tout l'appareil d'État régalien
dit en off, les les les responsables des
services de la police, de l'armée et
cetera. Tout ça, c'est des discussions
qui sont aujourd'hui quasi quotidiennes
au sein de ces professionnels. Mais nous
sommes quelques-uns, on a quelques-uns
comme observateur et analystes à faire
parfois des immersions périscopiques
pour en parler. Euh mais euh quand un
observateur ou un analyste le dit, c'est
déjà pas réjouissant, mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'impact que ça a quand c'est
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
encore en fonction pour 5 minutes qui
qui vient le dire. Donc on est euh
aujourd'hui dans une situation qui est
une situation qui est parfaitement
identifiée mais les politiques sont un
peu tétanisés. C'est un peu comme dans
je me souviens plus de ce film, je sais
plus si c'est avec Schwarseneger ou ou
Stallone, pardon pour la pauvreté de la
référence, mais où il y a un shérif qui
fait le ménage dans sa ville et il a
cette fameuse phrase "Not under my
watch". C'est-à-dire pas sous ma
responsabilité et les sauf que lui il
fait le ménage parce que il ne tolère
pas que ce soit sous sa responsabilité.
Alors que euh les les politiques qui qui
ne nomment pas les choses, eux, ils ne
font pas le ménage. Ils mettent sous il
on a l'impression que qu'ils se
retiennent en priant simplement pour que
euh ça n'explose pas à alors que qu'ils
sont aux affaires. Moi, je dis
simplement qu'à un moment donné,
il y aura nécessairement des initiatives
politiques à prendre parce que de toute
façon, nous allons vers
on est dans un univers qui est tellement
tendu et on a commencé par ça tout à
l'heure avec l'image que je prenais de
ce sol en train de de de craquer que
soit l'État prend l'initiative avec les
avantages de la que que Close Vit a
expliqué en stratégie hein, c'est-à-dire
du lieu du moment du lieu des moments et
et des moyens euh soit l'état un jour.
C'est Sozu, ça
c'est Sunsu. Mais enfin, ils l'ont ils
l'ont ils l'ont ils l'ont tous dit,
hein. Et puis en même temps, c'est pas
c'est c'est de la quiconque a un peu
travaillé sur ces questions le comprend
très bien. Euh c'est vrai dans tous les
domaines. Et et euh soit on le fait en
le maîtrisant euh soit on le subira.
Mais je pense que tous les gens qui
travaillent sur ces questions sont
d'accord sur le fait que aujourd'hui on
n'arrivera pas à éviter
un moment de de très difficile sur le
territoire national. Et donc pour en
revenir à François Hollande, c'est vrai
que il y avait un décalage entre ce
qu'il a pu dire en off et ce qu'il
disait on qui était mais qui était
tellement criant que c'était çaen était
ça en devenait ça en devenait gênant.
Cette inaction vous vous l'expliquiez
par quoi ? Et après moi le déluge, je
veux pas que je veux pas laisser le mon
nom dans l'histoire française comme
celui qui a shooté dans la fourmilière.
C'est quoi
? C'est simplement un manque de courage.
C'est
un manque des des problèmes de soutien
électoraux peut-être. Alors, je pense
que je pense que c'est un peu de tout
ça. Votre premier argument est très
juste. Je crois que aujourd'hui chez les
femmes et chez les hommes politiques,
personne n'a envie d'être celui qui sera
désigné par certains comme étant à
l'origine d'une à l'origine d'une d'une
opération de reconquête he parce que le
terme est utilisé mais enfin pas pas
toujours avec le même sens qui aura
dans le cadre de laquelle l'autorité de
l'État se sera exprimée par en
mobilisant un certain nombre de de
services régéliens
la police la justice, les douanes, le
fisque, hein. Il faut je pense qu'il
faut des des actions combinées de des
actions coup de point combiné mais dont
on sait que elles ne laisseront pas les
gens qui seront dérangés par ces par ces
par ces actions sans réaction et il y
aura donc nécessairement des heures des
heures violents et vraisemblablement des
morts. Et donc je pense que la première
raison, c'est que des femmes et des
hommes politiques aujourd'hui ne veulent
pas apparaître comme étant responsable
alors qu'en réalité il ne le serait pas
puisqu'il il il mettrai en place des
mesures qui qui sont des mesures qui qui
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure soit
on soit on domine le truc et on le fait
soit à un moment donné on le subira et
quand on le subit on sait que ça se
passe beaucoup plus mal. Donc il y a ça
mais il y a aussi peut-être même avant
ça un un crédau parce que ce qu'on dit
là c'est pas gay. Je veux dire, c'est
même c'est c'est c'est un côté
terrifiant si on fait un pas de côté. Et
je pense qu'il y a encore des des des
responsables politiques qui ont l'espoir
irrationnel que ça va s'arranger. Vous
avez par exemple tout un courant de
pensée qui considère que tout ça n'est
que le résultat du déclassement de la
pauvreté et de la situation économique
et que si d'un coup de baguette magique
dont on y voit mal comment il pourrait
avoir lieu. Peu importe pour les besoins
du raisonnement, s'il y avait une
amélioration structurelle de la
situation économique du pays, ces
problèmes disparaîtraient comme par
enchantement. Ceux-là n'ont pas compris
la dimension identitaire du problème qui
est qui qui est une une dimension
profonde enquistée dans le dans dans
notre dans notre société. que veulent
que là où je pense que les les
politiques qui sont dans cette erreur
d'analyse se trompent, c'est que la
population dans sa majorité, je pense
est prête à ça.
Prête à quoi ? À ce que les cités soient
en à ce qui est à un moment donné euh
des opérations qui soient des opérations
maîtrisées, des opérations réfléchies,
des opérations planifiées, pas des
opérations décidées à la va vite et en
disant on va tout raser. C'est pas du
tout ça que je dis. C'est des opérations
de reconquête républicaines qui ne
soient qui ne soient pas simplement le
fait de dire "On va mettre 15 policiers
de plus euh dans dans une cité de 10000
personnes où euh on sait très bien que
ça va changer. Allez, on va être
gentil." Peu de choses hein, pour ne pas
dire pas du tout.
Un petit match de foot.
Un petit Ouais, un petit match de foot.
Ça là, je déconseille aujourd'hui le
match de foot entre les policiers et les
autres. Le weekend dernier, le Figaro a
écrit que que qu'un policier c'est qui
jouait au foot dans avec son équipe du
dimanche hein, pas avec une équipe de
policier, s'est fait détroncher comme on
dit, c'est-à-dire s'est fait identifier
et que résultat le match a fini en
bagarre et le policier a été blessé par
les gens contre qui il jouent au foot.
Donc je déconseille aujourd'hui d'aller
faire des matchs de foot entre les les
les fauteurs de trouble et les policiers
parce que je pense que s'il y a un
match, c'est pas sur un terrain de foot
qui va se dérouler. Mais euh la ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la reconquête
puisque tout le monde tout le monde n'a
que ce mot à la bouche. Donc il y a au
moins on a compris que il fallait ce qui
dit reconquête dit besoin de
reconquérir. Donc sur l'audit on
commence à être d'accord pas forcément
sur la gravité mais euh c'est quand même
un mot qui est intrinsèquement fort.
Mais sur les moyens, je pense que si un
gouvernement mettait en place un plan
d'action
en le préparant tranquillement, en
impliquant différents acteurs, je vous
disais tout à l'heure, mais mais c'est
important d'y revenir. Bon, les forces
de sécurité intérieure pour assurer la
sécurité de l'opération, mais également
tous les services, la justice, la
douane, le fisque, des des services
sociaux pour apporter des aides
ponctuelles parce que il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont sur ces territoires et qui
en peuvent plus, qui ont envie qu'il y
ait un rétablissement de l'ordre
républicain, qui ont envie de pouvoir
vivre, de pouvoir sortir, de de pouvoir
retrouver une échelle républicaine qui
fonctionne en pouvant bosser, aller à
l'école, aller à la fac, essayer de de
de venir de de de de se réaliser
personnellement et et de s'intégrer
complètement dans la République.
Heureusement, il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont qui en ont envie, mais c'est de
plus en plus difficile pour eux. Donc à
un moment donné, je pense qu'il faudra
le faire et je pense que je et vraiment
moi je fais des conférences dans toute
la France, les gens ils sont prêts, les
gens n'en peuvent plus. Et quand je vous
dis les gens, je parle pas de de franche
d'excité d'extrême et cetera. Pas du
tout. Je vous parle des des des CSP
moyen plus, des gens qui bossent, des
commerçants, des cadres intermédiaires,
des cadres supérieurs, des professions
libérales. Et il y a un euh je je voilà
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
vraie demande de du public.
Bon, j'ouvre une parenthèse. Bon, après
cette opération carcher coup de balai
pour reprendre les mots de SarkoZi.
Ouais.
Le budget de la justice française, il en
est où ?
Le budget de la justice française, c'est
le néant.
C'est le Non, mais
le budget le budget des services sociaux
avec la crise économique qu'on se tape,
c'est le néant. Tout le monde est en
train de se faire rétrécir son short.
Donc ensuite les prisons, on les met en
prison, on fait quoi ? On les met en
centre de rééducation, on les déchoit de
leur nationalité, on les renvoie où ? On
en fait quoi ? Alors là, il y a plein de
il y a plein de questions en une.
Ça tombe bien, il y en a plein. Il a
plein de temps.
Puis on a le temps. Euh
la justice
aujourd'hui euh la justice est traitée
par l'État, mais c'est aujourd'hui,
hier, avant-hier. He je je ne je ne fais
pas porter la responsabilité plus sur ce
gouvernement, sur sur ce sur cet
exécutif que que sur les que sur les
précédents. Tout le monde est tout le
monde dans le même sac sur le sujet. Euh
on a aujourd'hui
une justice qui n'a pas les moyens
humains et matériels de remplir ses
missions. Euh à la fin de l'été, la
plupart des tribunaux ont épuisé leur
budget de fonctionnement. Les
fonctionnaires sont obligés de ramener
des des crayons et des ramètres de
papier de chez eux. Il y a même des cas
où les leasings des photocopieuses ne
sont plus payés. Donc on a vu des
endroits où les propriétaires sont venus
reprendre la photocopieuse. Enfin, il y
a il y a c'est une c'est un
dysfonctionnement structurel absolument
hallucinant.
Ça ressemble ça ressemble un peu à
l'Afrique, non ?
Écoutez, je je connais pas bien les pays
africains, mais en tout cas ça pourrait
ressembler à une caricature qu'on s'en
fait.
La caricature des pays africains, c'est
on donne pas d'argent au ministère de la
justice pour pouvoir faire ces petites
magouilles tranquillement. Alors, les
petites magouilles tranquillement, je
sais pas, il y a euh sans doute sans
doute dans la paupérisation de de de la
justice financière depuis 15 ans une
volonté politique. Bon, sans doute mais
euh mais en tout cas, ce qui est
certain, c'est que sur la la lutte
contre la délinquence, c'estàd sur la
justice, la justice du quotidien, mais
c'est pas seulement la lutte contre la
délinquence. La justice du quotidien,
c'est aussi euh euh le les divorces,
c'est aussi tout ce qui tout tout ce qui
fait tous les rendez-vous avec la
justice que de dont on besoin les les
les justiciables. Mais pour en revenir à
aux questions sur sur la délinquence qui
sont euh qui qui sont au cœur de notre
problématique, c'est absolument certain
que on y faisait allusion tout à l'heure
très vite, mais revenons-y 2 minutes. On
a aujourd'hui
dans l'organisation, il y a même même
dans le nombre de magistrats, dans le
manque de greffiers et cetera, il y a il
y a des à mon avis des tas de choses
qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait revoir.
Mais il y a surtout une espèce
d'habitude. On me dit souvent, il y a
des gens qui disent "Ouais, les
magistrats, ils sont laxistes, ils sont
de gauche et cetera et cetera." Moi,
j'en suis pas si sûr. J'en connais plein
de magistrats qui sont des gens euh
dévoués, qui bossent et qui ont une
vision sincère de de de de leur métier
et que et et et qui ont bien compris ce
que la société attendait d'eux. Mais il
y a un autre problème, c'est une espèce
d'habitude. C'est-à-dire que c'est on a
il y a l'habitude de la première chance,
de la deuxième chance, de la troisème
chance, de la 10e première chance.
Beaucoup de magistrats se rendent pas
compte parce que parce que c'est très
perturbant que quand vous prenez un
délinquant euh qui qui est
multirécidiviste, quand euh si vous
l'interrogez, d'ailleurs souvent dans
les salles d'audience, on entend ça, on
demande aux gens "Monsieur euh est-ce
que est-ce que vous avez déjà été
condamné ?" Le juge lui demande alors
qu'il a le casier sous les yeux, mais
c'est juste pour voir un petit peu
comment le le gars va réagir. Et le le
délinquent ne mentionne comme
condamnation que le nombre de fois où il
a été en prison. Donc un gars qui a été
condamné 10 fois et qui a été deux fois
en prison, il va vous répondre "Oui,
j'ai été condamné deux fois." Voyez ?
Donc les huit autres, il va considérer
que c'est pas que que c'est que c'est
pas une condamnation et donc que il va
le ressentir lui comme étant lui le
délinquant comme étant un aveu de
faiblesse de la société là où le juge
l'aura sans doute vécu comme étant une
main tendue et une décision mur pesée.
Donc il y a une il y a une
incompréhension totale entre celui qui
donne la sanction et celui qui la
reçoit. Qu'est-ce que c'est une juste
sanction ? Caria l'a dit beaucoup mieux
que moi. C'est une sanction qui est
certaine, c'estàd
qui est comprise
et qui est comprise
et et qui est et qui est comprise et et
dans le meilleur des cas accepté mais en
tout cas au moins comprise.
certaines
quand vous avez si vous prenez les les
les doléances des policiers, les
policiers disent de façon parfois
caricaturale mais pas toujours, on en a
assez d'arrêter les mecs et de et et de
les arrêter 15 fois et 15 fois ils sont
sortis le lendemain et et les magistrats
vont vous dire "Oui, mais c'est plus
compliqué que ça" et cetera et cetera.
Donc il faut il il faut à un moment que
les les tous ces gens les policiers et
les magistrats sont les mêmes maillons
du sont les les maillons d'une même
chaîne. C'estàd que le policier c'est le
premier maillon sur le terrain et le
magistrat qui juge c'est le dernier
maillon c'est celui qui qui sanctionne.
Après il y a l'administration
pénitentiaire mais c'est la même chaîne.
Si on n'est pas si les réglages sont
trop différents. C'est comme dans un
moteur. fois, je suis pas un je suis pas
un grand technicien, mais si vous avez
les éléments de de moteur qui sont pas
réglés pareil, vous allez quand même
avoir du du mal à faire avancer votre
voiture de façon de de de façon
équilibrée.
Ça risque de faire épuiser le premier
maillon.
Voilà. Donc euh dernière chose
là-dessus, enfin sauf si vous me avez
d'autres questions bien sûr, euh la
prison, l'autorité, l'autorité, il faut
rétablir, il c'est mais ça c'est c'est
alors je suis pas le premier à le dire
hein, je rien inventé, mais il est
absolument impératif de rétablir dans
tous les échelons, dans tous les les
niveaux de la société de l'autorité que
l'autorité soit ressentie. Pas écraser
les gens, pas de l'injustice. Il faut
faire très attention. L'autorité doit
être juste. Mais l'autorité, quand on
vous dit aujourd'hui, même le ministre
de l'intérieur a dit la semaine dernière
euh je pense que la prison est
criminogène. Mais mais je suis désolé,
la prison elle elle est elle est elle
est absolument pas crimine. Il y a
peut-être 15 dans une pièce.
Vous vous me devancez. Formidable. Vous
savez ce que je vais dire à l'avance ?
Ce qui est criminogène, c'est les
conditions de la prison. Mais la
société, elle a le droit même le devoir
de de punir. C'est pas la seule c'est
pas la seule c'est pas la la la seule
mission de la sanction. On en parlait
tout à l'heure avec Beécaria pour pour
que ce soit compris, il faut queil y ait
favorisé la réinsertion et cetera et
cetera. Mais il y a quand même une
dimension de punition. Elle fait partie
de la de la sanction. Pour ça, il faut
que cette punition soit juste de quel le
bon curseur et donc pas trop haut mais
pas non plus trop bas. Donc, il faut que
ce soit compris comme une punition,
hein, on est d'accord ? Et ensuite, il
faut que les moyens de l'exécution de
l'exécuter ne soi pas des moyens
désastreux. Là, on est d'accord. Mais
quand on vous dit quand vous avez une
espèce de doxa qui dit "Depuis que je
suis avocat, moi ça fait 24 ans que je
suis avocat, depuis que je suis avocat,
j'entends euh il y a trop de il y a pas
assez de place de prison ou plus
exactement il y a trop de gens en
prison." On vous dit il y a trop de gens
en prison. Non, il y a pas assez de
place de prison. On est dans le dernier
tiers des pays de de de euh d'Européens
sur le nombre de places de prison euh
par par habitant. Euh
comment vous expliquez que les pays
nordiques ferment les places de prison ?
Parce qu'il y a il y a plus de
délinquants.
Enfin, je sais pas s'il y a plus de
délinquants ou s'ils ont eux-mêmes des
des une manière de de de sanctionner. Je
je suis pas sûr qu'il fallait prendre
les pays nordiques en exemple quand on
voit par exemple ce qui se passe en
Suède sur l'évolution. Euh voilà hein,
je pense que les les pays nordiques,
attention, non, il y a la Hollande,
c'est vrai que la Hollande est une
espèce de de contreexemple. Mais alors,
je ne me suis pas penché, j'ai pas
analysé en détail, donc je vais pas vous
dire de bêtises. Je je pense simplement
qu'il faut pas confondre nos prisons
sont vides avec nos prisons sont vides
parce que il y a pas besoin de de les
remplir plus. Il y a peut-être aussi
là-bas des questions de sanctions qui
sont pas adaptées, je ne sais pas. Donc
je ne me lance pas. Petite question pour
vous déconcentrer un petit peu, c'est un
peu l'habitude de notre chaîne de couper
de de du cocalan
pour ou contre la légalisation du
cannabis.
Alors ça c'est un j'ai j'hésite beaucoup
sur cette question. Euh intuitivement,
je suis contre parce que je pense que le
le cannabis je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
est tout le monde est à peu près enfin
tout le monde est d'accord. Je suis pas
sûr que tout le monde soit d'accord mais
j'ai j'ai lu pas mal de travaux et les
dégâts du du cannabis, les dégâts de
long terme de du cannabis sur le
cerveau,
un peu comme l'alcool, non ?
Font que euh Ouais, un peu comme
l'alcool. Je je je très sincèrement je
je pense quand même plus que l'alcool.
Après ça dépend à quel à quel degré mais
l'addiction au cannabis peut vite avoir
des effets et notamment
il y a aucune addiction au cannabis que
psychologique addiction physique à
l'alcool et on on reparlera. Si si vous
je dis non, je finis juste je juste ma
phrase. Je bon je suis pas un
spécialiste de la question. J'observe
juste bon de façon empirique hein que
chez les jeunes qui fument beaucoup de
cannabis il y a il y a il y a il y a a y
il y a un décrochage scolaire qui qui
peut être très rapide et qui
où le décrochage scolaire vient et il
fume du cannabis pour se réfugier. OK,
on reviendra. On je n'ai pas de voilà,
j'ai pas de mais j'ai pas une religion
ferme sur le sujet.
Donc là on vous a bien déconcentré.
Allez,
on va passer, on a on reviendra sur le
terrorisme islamiste un peu plus tard et
tout ce qui est de guerre. J'aimerais
qu'on parle du terrorisme financier qui
est à notre sens le premier vecteur de
mort au sein même de notre monde.
C'est-à-dire que je reviens de 4 jours
de colloque sur le terrorisme avec un
singang de journalistes international
où il y avait des généraux tout un tout
un tas de choses. Ils étaient tous à à
dire ou là là là il il y a plein de
problèmes, il faut des programmes
éducatifs, il faut tout ça. La question
que je leur ai posé c'est qu'est-ce que
vous pensez du terrorisme financier ?
Alors là, ils m'ont regardé avec des
yeux ronds comme des billes. Qu'est-ce
que vous entendez par le terrorisme
financier ?
Alors, ça c'est ma première réponse,
donc je laisse y répondre.
Voà. Donc oui, je je devance un petit
peu. Ceux qui planquent l'argent à
gauche à droite, ceux qui ne payent pas
leur taxes, l'évasion fiscale, les
chambres de compensation et je vous en
passe des meilleurs. Ceux qui privent
l'État de sa capacité éducative de de
justice, de budget pour son ministère de
la justice, ainsi de suite. Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez du terrorisme financier
? Et est-ce que notre justice ou est-ce
que nos enquêteurs sont équipés pour
aller attraper cette upper classe du
terrorisme qui se cache derrière les
temps d'art de la philanthropie de on en
passé des meilleurs. Est-ce que vous
avez un peu abordé le le sujet dans
votre tank ?
Alors non, mais par contre là c'est plus
l'avocat qui va vous répondre. Euh j'ai
le sentiment euh c'est pas un sentiment
hein, je constate que euh l'organisation
euh juridique autour de ces questions
quand même beaucoup structuré depuis
quelques années et que depuis
depuis allez on va dire on va dire
depuis une petite dizaine d'années et
plus encore depuis depuis mais en lien
avec le terrorisme en conséquence de de
la des politiques mises en place contre
le terrorisme
physique he dont on parlait tout à
l'heure. Il y a des euh des mesures
des des mesures de de plus en plus
strict alors ou de moins en moins
laxiste. Je vous laisse je vous laisse
corriger si vous voulez mais qui sont
mis en place aujourd'hui. Vous avez euh
beaucoup d'argent qui a été récupéré par
l'État chez les d'uprès de gens qui
avaient des comptes à l'étranger et
cetera. Alors, je sais pas ce que ça
représente par définition, hein. Mais
oui, vous faites ce geste là, mais c'est
ce geste là en plus de ce qu'il y avait
avant.
C'est-à-dire que Ouais, c après c'est
une question de non le le travail de
trackf par exemple depuis quelques
années euh a permis quand même de de de
limiter de de limiter c'est plus
totalement la fête, ça l'a été. C'est
plus totalement la fête. Je suis
d'accord avec vous. Je vois votre
scepticisme sur le visage que n les
internautes ne voient pas. Euh c'est ça
pourrait sans doute être mieux mais il y
a des il y a des mécanismes qui ont été
mis en place. Euh, prenez un pays comme
la Suisse par exemple euh qui euh
aujourd'hui enfin qui depuis euh depuis
2008 ou 9 je crois euh sous la sous la
pression des États-Unis euh a quand même
pris des dispositions qui font que tous
les tous les les la vieille France qui
avait des comptes à l'étranger et cetera
et puis la France nouvelle euh dentiste
ou non qui avait des comptes à
l'étranger aussi euh faisait
chirurgien des cheveux.
Oui, chirurgien, pardon, c'est je
voulais dire c'est c'est ce que je
voulais dire. Pardon ? Pardon pour les
dentistes qui nous regardent, c'était
une mauvaise blague ratée sur le
chirurgien des cheveux, on est d'accord.
Euh je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile. Moi tous les gens euh les les
commerçants, tous les gens que je peux
croiser me disent que en France
aujourd'hui, il y a beaucoup moins de
cash qu'avant mais que même qu'il y a 3
ans. Donc il y a une mesure euh alors
par contre je me rends pas du tout
compte si ça frappe juste euh le le
petit commerce et les gens qui sont dans
des euh ou les gros groupes. Ça ça moi
je j'en sais rien. Donc je pense quand
même, mais en tout cas ma première
action c'est de dire que je suis
complètement d'accord sur le fait que il
y a une somme avec les les
délocalisations, les paradis fiscaux, y
compris en Europe avec l'Irlande et
cetera, il y a une masse fiscale
d'argent qui échappe à l'État et qui
pourrait servir à
de la pauvreté. Non, mais tout ça, je
suis d'accord avec vous. Mais euh je si
je regarde la bouteille à moitié pleine,
je me dis que les choses euh ont quand
même beaucoup évolué en peu de temps. Et
très sincèrement comme euh avocat
pénaliste qui traite parfois des
dossiers financiers euh importants, euh
vous m'auriez posé la question il y a 10
ans en me disant en 2018 ce sera comme
ça. J'aurais été très sceptique. Donc
vous voyez, on part peut-être de très
loin, mais je trouve qu'on avance quand
même un petit peu. Maintenant, si vous
voulez me faire dire à moi qui suis très
impliqué sur les questions de sécurité,
sur le l'importance de de de développer
les moyens de de de de tous les
ministères régelliens, à commencer par
la justice dont on parlait tout à
l'heure, si vous voulez me faire dire
que il faudrait absolument qu'il
faudrait que l'État ait plus de
ressources
et que il y a une partie de ces
ressources qui se trouvent, il y a des
gisements là où vous venez l'ennemi est
mal désigné parce que désigner l'ennemi
du terrorisme comme premier ennemi
d'État, oui, mais peut-être que le vrai
ennemi terroriste qui crée toutes ces
toutes ces ces herzates ou ces
métastases, c'est le terrorisme
financier. Non,
alors je suis pas je je pense pas parce
que la ce qui est sous-jacent dans votre
question, c'est que le terrorisme
islamiste aurait fleuri sur uniquement
sur ce que je vais faire court mais sur
la paupérisation, c'est sur les
problèmes économiques. Je moi je pense
pas du tout. Je pense que il y a c'est
un facteur aggravant indiscutable. Non
mais indiscutable, ça je suis d'accord.
Je je conteste évidemment pas ce point.
Par contre euh le
on a évidemment le constat de ce que les
les islamistes en Europe euh sont des
gens qui qui sont dans dans une logique,
on en a parlé tout à l'heure, dans une
logique politique avec un projet, avec
des textes, avec des stratégies voilà et
que et qu'elles ne sont pas nées de la
de la paupérisation, elles sont nées de
leur de leur présence de plus en plus
nombreuses en Europe. Est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a un marché de la lutte contre
le terrorisme ? C'est celui celui qui
fait les qui fait les bombes et ensuite
celui qui fait le le dispositif anti euh
djihadis qui revient en France de
surveillance, de contrôle, de matraque,
de bouclier, euh tout le dispositif dans
le dur. Est-ce qu'il y a un marché du
terrorisme ?
Parce que aussi ça fait vendre la
presse, ça fait vendre la presse, ça
fait des gros titres. les politiques
aussi. Je vais je vais être très cynique
et il faudra pas mal interpréter mes
mots, mais il y a des gens qui aiment le
terrorisme parce que ça fait faire du
fric. Le journaliste, il fait ses
éditoriaux, il en parle, écr ses débats.
L'homme politique, dès qu'il y a un
attentat, il récupère cinq points de
popularité parce qu'il a tapé un peu du
point sur la table. Le marchand d'armes,
il aime bien parce que comme ça
derrière, il va récupérer du pognon
public pour faire pour équiper les gens
en surveillance, en tout ça. Il y a un
marché quand même, non ? Alors, c'est
absolument certain qu'il y a un marché
de la secteur
et c'est toujours les mêmes qui gèrent
ces questions-là,
sauf de temps en temps un avocat qui
essaie des expériments c'est pas le
sujet. Euh le la sécurité, ça c'est
absolument certain qu'il y a un marché
de la sécurité, on le voit hein, qui est
en plein essort. Euh euh mais qui alors
est-ce que les gens est-ce que ça
correspond est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il
y a un marionettiste cynique qui
organise tout ça ? Très sincèrement, moi
je pense pas. J'ai pas dit
marionettiste, j'ai dit que
opportunistes, des gens qui Mais
regardez, regardez si on remonte. Alors,
je suis pas expert international, moi je
travaille beaucoup sur la France mais ça
m'empêche pas de regarder autour.
Si vous prenez l'affaire poste 11
septembre 2001, on sait aujourd'hui que
les néoconservateurs américains étaient
dans une logique qui a été favorisée par
ce qui s'est passé
comme elle était mais elle était déjà
sur la tendance des des attentats de 98
au Kenya et cetera. Elle était de c'est
c'était une tendance mais que il y a eu
la la l'exacerbation du terrorisme
islamiste et l'ennemi Al-Qaïda a
favorisé tout le lobby
militarauoindustriel américain. Ça c'est
absolument certain. la guerre en
Afghanistan suivie par la guerre en Irak
euh suivie par du coup bah la guerre
quasiment sans nonstop hein jusqu'à
aujourd'hui a conduit euh le le lobby
militaro industriel à s'enrichir
considérablement et les décisions de
Donald Trump en matière de de budget
militaire depuis qu'il est depuis qu'il
est élu président des États-Unis vont
toujours dans le même sens. Donc
objectivement la réponse à votre
question est oui. Maintenant est-ce
qu'ils s'en réjouissent ? Alors ce qui
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est une
franche de terroriste ? La vraie
question.
Moi je pense pas mais je suis peut-être
naïf mais je pense pas. qui en est qui
se si vous voulez
le le gars on va caricaturer on va faire
de de soyons soyons marxiste de
l'actionnaire l'actionnaire Carl ou de
l'actionnaire de chez Black Water non
mais lui il est il est content de de de
prendre le cash en fin d'année euh de
s'acheter une plus belle maison, un jet
et cetera sans doute. Mais le le
responsables, les les gens qui sont aux
affaires dans dans ces pays, moi j'ai la
j'ai la la la faiblesse de pensé. Mais
alors là, je je je j'accepte le procès
en naïveté, mais enfin en France, j'en
connais quand même pas mal et
il me donne l'impression d'une grande
sincérité quand je quand ils
m'apparaisent à la fois perdu, parfois
naïfs, ne comprenant pas et cetera. On
en a parlé tout à l'heure, mais euh à
aucun moment je n'ai rencontré des gens
ne me laissant me disant, gen j'en parle
même pas évidemment, mais me laissant
penser que euh c'est c'est que c'est que
finalement tout ça est super parce que
ça permet d'eux et cetera.
Ils sont naif ou ils sont profondément
cons ?
Non, ils sont pas cons.
Non,
non. Bah, il y en a, je dire, il y a des
cons partout bien sûr, mais c'est pas la
c'est pas la c'est pas la majorité. Ils
sont formatés. Ils sont for Ce qui est
pas du tout pareil. les les politiques
en France sont très formatées. On
parlait tout à l'heure de thinking out
of the box. Enfin, j'ai pasé
l'expression mais j'en ai une expression
euh similaire. Euh moi je crois beaucoup
queil faut regarder les ce qui se passe
en ce moment avec euh en enlevant les
œillères et en s'interdisant euh aucune
aucune remarque réflexion et la vôtre
sur le financement était fait évidemment
partie de de la de de l'image globale.
Je pense que ça c'est un exercice auquel
les élites françaises ont beaucoup de
mal à s'habituer parce que on a un pays
qui fonctionne et ça a été son ça a été
aussi la sa part de succès, la
reconstruction après la deuxième guerre
mondiale et cetera et cetera avec des
grandes écoles, avec des élites mais
avec des gens qui du coup on ont
beaucoup de mal à sortir de schéma de de
prê d'un prête à penser qui est un prête
à penser qui en plus a fait ses preuves
puisqu'il a relancé le pays et qui est
confortable parce que quand on vous
donne le prête à penser, bah c'est plus
la peine de se faire mal à la tête en se
disant merde et si et cetera et cetera.
Et quand quelqu'un vient vous dire "Ah
ouais mais si quand même on se mettait
un petit peu à côté du cadre général
pour se poser la question et cetera, bah
vousz l'emmerdeur de service et on
trouve un moyen de vous ostraciser.
Alors les Staliniens psychiatrisaient
les gens là on peut on va vous traiter
selon les cas de fou de fachaot
de de voilà de de tout ça. Mais euh donc
ça des gens comme ça, j'en ai vu. Mais
de plus en plus quand même les gens que
je rencontre alors c'est peut-être aussi
parce qu'ils acceptent de me rencontrer.
On sent quand même, ils cherchent ils
cherchent une nouvelle grille de
lecture. Ils sont ils sont en demande.
Euh
ils sont en demande ou ils sont en
panique ?
Un pied dans chaque.
Bon euh on ferme cette petite
parenthèse, on nous on nous rouvre une
autre. Est-ce que la France a une
diplomatie schizophrène ? Est-ce que le
fait de de continuer à faire du business
avec l'Arabie Saoudite ou des pays peu
fréquentables comme diraient certains
députés LREM, est-ce que c'est pas
vecteur de terrorisme ? Est-ce que c'est
pas alimenter le le chien qui nous mort
? Alors, je vous disais tout à l'heure,
je suis encore une fois je suis pas un
spécialiste de de la de la question
internationale. Encore une fois, ça
m'empêche pas d'avoir euh un avis sur un
certain nombre de choses, mais peut-être
moins documenté que sur ce qui se passe
dans notre pays. Euh,
d'abord la sur l'Arabie Saoudite, il
faut il y a beaucoup de gens oublient
une chose, c'est que l'Arabie Saoudite,
ça existe pas. C'est pas un pays, c'est
des centaines de tribus avec des chefs
tribaux qui s'organisent les uns les
autres en faisant d'ailleurs souvent
régner une forme de violence politique
que dont on a peu d'idées en Europe. Et
euh donc il y a pas il y a pas il y a
pas un représentant du peuple élu et les
Arabes d'Arabie Saoudite considéreraient
que donc au sein des mêmes tribus, on a
des des des des grands écarts. On a
c'est célèbre mais Ben Laden était le
cousin de de gens qui étaient très
proches du pouvoir et cetera.
Donc déjà, il y a il y a c'est très
difficile de parler d'un la la la
vision qu'on a de enfin on unifie, on
projette hein, mais ça c'est un souvent
un problème qu'on a, c'est qu'on
projette sur des pays qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir, ni dans leur
culture, ni dans leur organisation, ni
dans leur histoire,
nos propres règles, nos propres manières
de fonctionner sur sur ce pays. Ensuite
donc c'est important parce que selon des
des tribus au pouvoir et même des gens
au sein d'une tribu, on le voit en ce
moment avec MBS qui est le fils de son
père mais qui en même temps agit
complètement différemment et à un point
tel que il est pas complètement interdit
de penser qu'il va y avoir une reprise
en main sous la pression de de de de des
pays des États-Unis et autres peutè hein
mais bon donc c'est très difficile de
parler d'une politique
de politique à politique ensuite mais ça
vous m'avez pas attendu pour pour le
savoir. Le problème, c'est un problème
d'énergie fossile. Euh on a on on peut
pas aujourd'hui se permettre le luxe de
dire à à des pays comme l'Arabie
Saoudite et quelques autres "Allez-vous
faire [__] tout simplement parce que
on a économiquement besoin." Bah
c'est sûr que si on met des sanctions à
la Russie, à l'Iran et qu'on se met les
mains dans le que dans l'Arabie
Saoudite, on est pied point lié.
Ah ben voilà. Donc il y a plus qu'à
conduire des éoliennes et à pédaler dans
le massif central. Vous voyez, je veux
dire, il y a un moment où c'est pas
c'est pas réaliste. C'est d'ailleurs une
très grande hypocrisie parce que quand
on va donner des leçons de droit de
l'omisme au monde entier, on va
renverser
tout tous les pays stables autour de
nous, on les on les on les a cassé. Donc
c'est pas compliqué aujourd'hui quand
même ce qui nous arrive. Moi, je suis
pas du tout un adepte de dire c'est de
notre faute et de flageller et cetera.
Je suis même plutôt l'inverse. Mais par
contre ça politiquement, on a une grande
part de responsabilité sur sur ce qui
est en train d'arriver à l'Europe. Ça ça
c'est sûr. Si vous prenez l'enchaînement
Maghreb, Libye, bon l'Égypte
mais et la Syrie,
c'est quand même c'est quand même
compliqué. C'est à se demander s'il y a
pas quelqu'un qui a stimulé tout ça pour
déstabiliser l'Europe. Non,
je pas sûr qu'on ait tellement besoin
d'être stimulé pour la Libye par
exemple.
Ouais. Non, mais pour l'Égypte, c'était
très intéressant de retrouver certains
fils de diplôate américain avec tout le
petit kit de révolutionnaire
avec des CD Rom, du cash et tout ce qui
va bien. Bon, c'était très intéressant.
Pour l'Arabie Saoudite, vous voulez
rajouter un mot ?
Non, peut-être pour le Qatar.
Oui, le Qatar.
Un mot sur le Qatar. Le Qatar et le
Qatar il est alors lui, il est très
clairement un pied dans chaque camp euh
mais que enfin c'est c'est assumé hein,
c'est c'est c'est notoire, c'est assumé.
Il y a un côté un frère musulman avec
gros financement de de de l'islamisme en
France et de l'autre les ventes d'armes,
le financement plus gros soutien de de
des politiques en France en particulier
avec un sujet là qui est on s'abroche
quand même des gros sujets tabou fou
remess non
entre autres. Oui. Euh le bouquin de
Malb Bruno qui qui qui George Malbrune
qui est nos chers émir qui est qui est
accueilli par un silence assourdissant.
C'est c'est extraordinaire avec il donne
des faits, des noms et cetera des gens
qui sont encore aujourd'hui dans la
politique française. Ça tout le monde a
l'air de s'en [__] Enfin bon, ne
changeons pas de sujet. Le euh ce que je
voulais juste dire sur le Qatar, c'est
que ils ont un pied dans chaque camp et
euh je je on en pense ce qu'on veut mais
ils y sont obligés parce que c'est un
confetti euh sur le sur la carte le
Qatar, c'est
bientôt une île
et ils c'est ça et donc euh il pourrait
être balayé en une demi-journée
militairement au sens propre hein, par
pas par tous leurs voisins euh ou par
des voisins un peu plus un peu un peu
plus lointains, genre de l'autre côté de
la mer. Et ils ont et donc je pense que
pour eux c'est une question de survie.
Alors ça c'est leur point de vue.
Maintenant, est-ce que nous on est
obligé de tout tolérer
à partir du moment où il financ une
partie de la vie politique française ?
Je pense que tant tant que ça ça ne
changera pas.
La même politique française qui est
chargé de nous protéger contre le
terrorisme.
On est bien d'accord. Vous savez, je
vais vous raconter une anecdote. Euh
quand j'étais en 1990, j'étais sergent
dans les paras et euh c'était le moment
de la guerre du golf, la première guerre
du golf. Donc vous vous souvenez le 2
août 90 Saddam Husin envahide le couet
et on met en place une coalition et
cetera et cetera. Là-dessus, je pars
début octobre dans les paras et je me
retrouve dans un dans un régiment à
l'époque qui s'appelait la force
d'action rapide. Bon bref, on arrive et
les gars nous disent tout de suite vous
êtes une génération, vous allez faire la
vraie guerre et cetera. Donc on a une
préparation ma costaud et à l'époque il
faisait des contrats pour pour la durée
de la guerre. Donc Miteran avait beau
dire il y a pas d'appelé dans le golf.
En réalité c'était juste des appelés qui
avaient signé un morceau de papier. Et
donc quand on se retrouve à
l'entraînement, c'était un entraînement
assez assez sérieux parce que les cadres
nous disaient vraiment on va y aller.
Et c'est là où le sens de mon anecdote,
je n'arrive j'en arrive au but. Et on a
un des cours sur l'armement iraaken
parce qu'on dit on va faire la guerre
contre les iraquiens dans quelques
semaines et cetera. Et là il y a
et là il y a un instructeur qui nous dit
"Vous inquiétez pas les gars, vous vous
connaissez tous les matos qu'ils ont,
c'est que des matos français qu'on leur
a vendu." Voilà.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'ajoute ?
C'est propre, hein. On va passer à deux
trois petites questions internet. Euh
que pensez-vous des mouvements militants
écolos et leur action de désobéissance
civile ?
H Alors, je pense que les Je pense que
d'abord je pense qu'il y a un vrai souci
sur le climat. Je sais pas si c'est la
question, mais c'est la première chose
que ça m'inspire.
Euh,
vous avez pas vu l'armée des 12 singes
vous ? Non
mais bon
c'est les écolos qui se radicalisent
tellement qui prennent un virus et qui
qui
Non mais alors j'y arrive j'y arrive. Je
pense que il y a toute une branche dure
notamment à à Bur par exemple euh de
gens qui sont euh mais aussi on a on a
on a pas tellement parlé de ce qui s'est
passé réellement à Notre Dame des Landes
hein euh où l'État a on a on a on a mis
en avant qu'il y avait eu une reprise et
cetera, mais sur les lieux vraiment
durs, il y a pas eu de reprise du tout
hein. Les les vrais affrontements ont
été évités. Donc le euh il y a des gens
qui sont dans une radicalisation
écolo qui qui est évidemment une
radicalisation violente mais ça je les
ai oublié dans mon énumération initiale
mais évidemment évidemment ça en fait
partie en lien ou pas avec l'extrême
gauche mais on a on a de toute façon
dans la lutte politique
une radicalisation partout. C'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui le le la violence est un
moyen d'expression de la de la lutte
politique chez quasiment tous les gens
qui ont une qui ont une revendication.
Est-ce que Est-ce que le capitalisme est
un est un terrorisme écologique ?
Ouh là, ça c'est quasiment de la philo
là. Euh
non, enfin je je comprends pas bien la
question. Alors, je vais essayer de de
la déayer un peu.
Toutes ces boîtes qui polluent à
longueur d'année, qui font du plastique
à gogo, qui participent au réchauffement
climatique, qui ont des lobbyes partout,
qui font de l'acquisition de
renseignement exactement comme un lobby
terroriste.
Est-ce que les mouvements écolo de
gauche, comme vous les décrivez ne sont
pas les les réminiscences, les
manifestations, la défense
de notre biotope ? Et est-ce qu'on les
appelle terroristes ? pour mieux les
décrédibiliser ou les discréditer.
Alors, je suis pas sûr qu'on les appelle
terroristes, hein. Pas
encore.
Pas encore. Bah, ça dépend. Après, s'ils
vont tuer des gens, enfin, c'est
toujours euh euh le
euh
je moi je pense que sur cette question
euh de l'environnement euh on peut
enfin, voyez, par exemple, moi
franchement, il y a rien dans ma culture
qui me prépare à ça, aux questions à la
sensibilité aux questions
d'environnement. Pourtant, j'y suis
sensibilisé aujourd'hui. J'ai mis du
temps mais j'y suis. Donc je pense pas
qu'il y ait besoin euh c'est pas des
actions violentes qui m'ont sensibilisé,
c'est de lire, c'est d'entendre des
experts, c'est de me renseigner, euh
c'est de constater aussi un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements et par
curiosité intellectuelle tout à coup de
me dire "Mais merde, il y a il y a il y
a quand même un problème." Donc à partir
de là, je pense qu'il peut y avoir des
mesures qui soient prises sans qu'il y
ait besoin de de de de d'une violence
qui qui risque d'avoir l'effet inverse
de ce qui est recherché, c'est de
décrédibiliser le le
j'allais dire l'idéologie, mais c'est
pas le bon mot parce que c'est pas une
idéologie, de décrédibiliser la le
l'alerte recherchée. Voilà.
Euh
autre question d'internet. Euh vous vous
proposez de rétablir euh de fait
l'autorité.
Hm.
C'est quoi vos pré préconisations ?
Bah alors, j'ai déjà décrit tout à
l'heure ce que ce que ce que je pensais
qu'il faudrait faire à un moment ou un
autre sur un certain nombre de
quartiers.
Moi
les encerclés, faire venir la douane, le
fisque, tout le monde.
Ouais. Voilà. De toutes les tout
ce qui a déjà été fait 25 fois hein.
Non non non non non. Pas pas. Ce qui a
pas été fait, c'est de voter des statuts
spéciaux pour ces territoires et de leur
appliquer une administration différente
parce que c'est ça
genre d'état d'urgence,
non pas enfin
gouvernement militaire
du genre non non mais du genre
simplement d'avoir des des textes qui
soient déjà avec les textes qui existent
a il y a un moyen de travailler ensuite
on peut rajouter on peut faire ça existe
déjà dans la loi il y a le maire de je
sais plus quelle ville qui l'a fait la
semaine dernière on peut faire des
couvre-feux on peut faire on peut faire
plein de choses. Ça va pas être une
façon de les les dossier désolidariser
désolidariser encore plus de la France ?
Ouais. Mais alors si vous voyez si si on
vous dit l'avocat du diable,
oui mais c'est Non mais c'est une c'est
une c'est une vraie question. C'est une
bonne question mais la question c'est de
savoir si est-ce qu'on se dit ou là là
c'est déjà ils sont déjà très on est on
est il y a déjà un séparatisme qui est
très avancé donc il faut les il faut les
il faut bah les reconquérir. On en
revient au mot qui est qui est à la mode
en ce moment et en même temps on va pas
mettre de on va pas prendre de de de de
mesures trop dures parce que les pauvres
il faut pas que il y a un moment où faut
se demander si on n pas déjà de l'autre
côté
et les reconquérir dans leur tête on
fait comment ? Alors, ça c'est important
et j'allais le reste aussi, mais c'était
c'était le c'était la suite de ma
réponse. C'était la suite de ma réponse
sur l'autorité. Euh si vous observez les
modes de recrutement euh des islamistes,
c'est très intéressant parce que ce soit
sur internet ou dans les ou ou ou dans
les mosquées hein parce que ça se passe
aussi c'est la mode de dire tout se fait
sur internet, c'est pas si simple que
ça. Il y a aussi beaucoup de de
recrutements en en face à face, en
physique et cetera et notamment aux
abords de certaines mosquées. Tout ça,
il faut quand même le dire aussi. Le
pitch, qu'est-ce que c'est ? c'est de
dire en gros je fais je le fais à gros
trait mais ça va me permettre d'avancer
ensuite sur la reconquête. C'est dire
regarde ces mécréants de coufar
c'està-dire vous et moi.
Ils se vautrent dans leur individualisme
ils ont ils ne croient plus à rien.
Ils sont abrutis par la télé, le foot,
les filles dénudées et cetera. Alors que
nous nous avons un projet et nous avons
un souffle. D'accord ? C'est comme ça
que les gens sont partis en Syrie
beaucoup parce qu'il y avait ce cette
exaltation d'aller combattre pour le
cham et cetera.
Il faut que nous recréons de la fierté
d'être d'être européen, d'être français
et d'être européen. Et pour ça, il faut
commencer. Vous savez, moi je suis un je
trouve que il y a beaucoup de choses de
leçons intéressantes à tirer de la
psychanalyse et c'est le fameux
connais-toi. Alors, il y a le
connais-toi des des des Grecs, il y a le
connais-toi
des des psychanalystes. Et si on fait
une synthèse des deux, qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça nous amène à quoi ? Ça
fait que si vous voulez, c'est vrai pour
les individus, c'est vrai pour les
sociétés. Si vous voulez vous sentir
bien dans votre vie et donc être bien
avec dans votre rapport à l'autre, il
faut vous connaître et accepter ce que
vous êtes et travailler sur le meilleur
de ce que vous êtes pour pour vous
bonifier. Et à ce moment-là, on peut
tendre la main aux gens et on peut dire
voilà moi je je vais être bien avec toi,
voilà comme je suis et pour qu'on soit
bien ensemble, il faut qu'on trouve un
un modus vivant dit. Mais en acceptant
ce que je suis et en acceptant que dans
l'interaction, il y a une limite que je
que je que je dont je ne tolère pas le
dépassement. Mais cool, vous voyez pour
ça, il faut il faut faut être bien dans
sa tête et et et avoir réfléchi à la
question. Au niveau d'un peuple, c'est
exactement
Je suis sûr que vous fumez du cannabis
au niveau au niveau du d'un peuple,
c'est exactement la même chose. C'est
exactement la même chose. Il faut que
Mais ça va prendre 20 ans. Qu'est-ce que
Qu'est-ce que nous sommes ? Qu'est-ce
que nous sommes les Français, les les
Européens ? Et où est-ce qu'on va ?
Non, mais ouais. Mais déjà, qu'est-ce
que nous sommes ? Qu'est-ce qu'on veut ?
Où est-ce qu'on va ? Doucement. Mais
qu'est-ce que nous sommes ? Nous sommes
un peuple. Nous sommes un peuple. Nous
sommes un peuple aux racines
greco-latines. On a des racines. On a
des racines qui descendent loin dans
l'histoire. C'est pas des racines d' a y
a 40 ans. C'est des racines qui
descendent loin avec une histoire, avec
des traditions qui se sont perpétrées
avec de des des des heures, avec des
massacres, avec des choses horribles.
Mais nous sommes il y a a y a il y a il
y a une cohérence dans tout ça. Il y a
une cohérence. Ces racines, elles sont
greco-latines. La tradition maintenant,
on a une tradition qui est
judéo-chrétienne.
D'accord ? Donc on a une gouvernance qui
qui est plutôt fondée sur la
bienveillance.
On peut rentrer après faire du tout.
Non, mais on va mais mais il y a eu mais
bien mais il y a eu des il y a eu des
moments il y a eu des moments qui sont
pas forcément glorieux euh mais
colonie la colonisation.
Ouais. Mais si vous faites la si vous
faites si vous comparez dans le temps
les temps de croisade de conquête et de
colonisation avec le les temps de
domination de des des des
comment le pardon j'ai le mot me manque
mais des califats et cetera, vous vous
rendrez compte que la la Ouais, c'est
c'est c'est kifkif. Je suis pas sûr même
que ce soit mini kiff pour nous et gros
kiff pour eux. Mais c'est c'est pas mon
c'est pas mon sujet. Moi la la question
c'est comment on rétablit c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on est ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
est ? C'est on s'accepte. On s'accepte y
compris avec nos phases notre phase
sombre. Il s'agit pas de la nier. Il
s'agit pas de faire du révisionnisme. Il
s'agit de dire "OK, on a pu de temps en
temps commettre des erreurs." Bien sûr,
qui n'en fait pas ? Qui n'en fait pas ?
"Ten fais pas, toi ? Tu en as jamais
fait ?" Ben moi, j'en ai fait,
j'accepte. J'en ai fait, mais j'ai
travaillé dessus, j'ai grandi dessus et
cetera. Et en tout cas, ça fait partie
de mon histoire, ça fait partie de ma
tradition, notre mode de gouvernance.
Ensuite, la place de la femme. Moi, je
crois beaucoup. Moi, je je il me reste
de l'espoir. Moi, mon grand espoir,
c'est que la reconquête en réalité, elle
se fasse par la femme. C'est-à-dire que
la la femme de dans la dans l'islam et
et notamment dans dans dans l'islam
radical, la place de la femme n'est pas
la même que dans notre civilisation. Ça
n'est pas la même mais ça n'a rien à
voir
ça. Ça vient d'où ça ? Ça
Mais ça vient ça vient des textes et ça
vient
J'ai lu le Coran. J'ai lu le camp bien
sûr, mais je prétends pas être un
exégèse et être capable de de
l'analyser. Donc, je suis extrêmement
prudent et et humble en la matière et je
je ne me je je vais certainement pas
vous citer des des sourates et vous
proposer de trône, il est pas mal quand
même hein. Ouais, mais bon. Non, mais
attendez, le restons sur la femme.
Restons sur la femme. Prenez l'affaire
asiibi la semaine dernière. Terrible,
terrible. au Pakistan, voilà cette femme
membre d'une minorité chrétienne qui va
boire de l'eau dans un puit un puit qui
est réservé aux musulmans et qui est
condamné à mort, qui est gracié. Et
après 3 jours de manif, euh il est en
train de se mettre en place un nouveau
process qui devrait qui pourrait aboutir
à nouveau à sa condamnation. Mais je
veux dire, faut voir de quoi on parle.
Euh nous en en Europe, la traduction
occidentale, je dis pas que tout a
toujours été parfait dans l'égalité
homme-femme, mais euh nous avons euh le
nous proposons euh à la femme euh de un
un une égalité et un accès euh à tout.
Alors, OK, vous allez me dire "Ouais,
mais euh euh balance ton port, le le
machisme et cetera." Je dis pas que
c'est parfait. Je dis simplement que
dans la loi et dans euh le mode de vie
de l'immense majorité de nos
compatriotes, la femme a une place à
part entière, ce qui n'est absolument
pas le cas euh dans les dans dans dans
l'islam radical. Et je pense que petit à
petit la sécularisation, parce que c'est
ça le la question, c'est que nous avons
aussi dans dans la liste des des vertus
euh dont je parle euh nous avons nous un
système qui est euh séculier euh et euh
ça ça fait pas si longtemps que ça. Or
le problème c'est que l'islam n'est pas
sécularisé aujourd'hui. L'islam est est
est est un est des principes de vie.
D'ailleurs dans tous les quartiers qui
sont devenus un copain policier qui m'a
dit il y a pas longtemps bah moi chez
moi j'ai une théocratie j'ai une mini
théocratie islamiste. Bon si ça veut
bien dire ce que ça veut dire. Ça veut
dire qu'il y a un petit quartier qui est
entièrement gouverné par la par la loi
musulmane. Donc vous avez euh un
tribunal pour le enfin un groupe de gens
qui se réunissent pour régler les
affaires commerciales en parallèle du
tribunal de commerce de la République
française. Pareil pour les affaires de
mœurs en parallèle de juges affaires
familiales français et cetera. Peu
importe, c'est dans Mais il y a plein
d'endroits comme ça en France. Il y en a
il y en a des centaines. Deux trois qui
à me donner.
Non, je je je laisse. Non non, ça je
peux tout ce que je peux vous dire,
c'est que selon les interlocuteurs qui
sont les miens dans toutes les
administrations régéliennes, la
fourchette basse de des quartiers où il
y a des difficultés de ce genre, c'est
700 et la fourchette haute, c'est 1200.
Voilà. Donc c'est pas forcément des
quartiers qui font des kilomètres
carrés, hein, mais c'est des quartiers.
Donc on est quand même sur un problème
sur un problème métastasique qui qui est
important. Mais j'en reviens au rôle de
la femme. Moi, je pense que la
nos compatriotes parce que faut pour
pour pas qu'il y a de malentendu, moi je
pense que la majorité de nos
compatriotes musulmans euh n'ont qu'une
envie, c'est de vivre comme vous et moi.
C'est-à-dire que la religion, euh ils
ont peut-être des traditions qui sont
les leurs, ils ont bien le droit d'avoir
leur tradition, mais c'est de l'ordre de
la vie privée et ils n'ont pas envie
d'en faire le moteur de leur vie.
D'accord ? C'est ça l'enjeu. Et je pense
que chez ces compatriotes
et bien ce qui peut faire vraiment la
bascule pour que il se sente
citoyen de la République française
membre de l'Union européenne, c'est la
place de la femme et c'est que la femme
soit déservie. Voilà, c'est vraiment
pour moi un point clé. Donc, j'oublie
pas la question d'origine sur comment
est-ce qu'on rétablit l'autorité dans
dans les cœurs. Je pense que si nous
nous montrons à nouveau fier de ce que
nous sommes et si nous montrons que nous
avons une aventure à vivre ensemble
autour de ces valeurs, autour de ces
valeurs-là,
on peut gagner. Je veux dire, on peut on
peut gagner. Non, mais il faut essayer.
Je je vous je vous avez une mou vous
avez une mou. Je sais pas.
Je regarde mon écran.
D'accord. Euh je pense, moi je pense que
pour faire court, je je pense que tout
n'est pas foutu. Je pense qu'il y a un
espoir. Le problème, c'est que la vague,
on est tellement dans le dur pour le
moment queen fait, il va falloir
combiner les deux. C'est-à-dire qu'il va
falloir combiner une autorité qui, à mon
avis, impliquera à un moment donné des
mesures extrêmement difficiles et en
même temps comme dirait l'autre euh des
euh une une
reconquête des euh des des des cœurs et
des âmes euh qui soit euh qui soit un
travail d'éducation.
Les mesures difficiles, c'est quoi ?
Bah, c'est ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure. C'est de ce dont on parlait
tout à l'heure dans dans les de
reconquête des quartiers et cetera.
Enfin, voilà, c'est ce qu'on a déjà dit.
Euh vous m'avez posé d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure la question sur la la des
nationalité et cetera. Bien sûr, enfin
je veux dire c'est une évidence. Les
gens qui ne vous savez aujourd'hui la la
peine complémentaire euh de euh
d'expulsion euh et d'interdiction du
territoire euh pour les gens qui sont
euh étrangers euh en justice he c'est un
étranger qui est condamné pour un délit
ou un crime peut-être euh en plus de sa
condamnation principale euh expulsé et
interdit du territoire français. Euh je
je sais plus combien il y a de dél de
crimes qu'il prévoit dans le code pénal,
mais il y en a beaucoup. Et euh je
lisais récemment que le taux
d'application de cette mesure par les
magistrats, il il est de l'ordre de 30
%. Mais c'est rien. Donc moi, je pense
que quand on est chez les gens, on se
conduit bien et que euh il n'y a aucune
raison mais aucune alors là on peut on
peut me sortir tous les poncifs de la
terre, je resterai sur ma position parce
que je beaucoup de débats sur le sujet.
Il y a aucune raison qui justifie qu'on
tolère que des gens qui se conduisent
mal chez nous pénalement sanction de et
qui sont pénalement sanctionnés ne soit
pas expulsé. Après, il y a le problème
des pays d'accueil qui veulent pas les
accueillir et cetera et cetera. Et je
pense que dans le cadre des politiques
de développement et de coopération, il
faudrait qu'il y ait des deals qui
soient faits. Enfin, ça ça existe déjà,
mais les renforcés sur ce point-là.
Autre question internet. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des Français de 2e ou 3e génération
d'immigrés qui n'ont pas nos racines ?
Bah, je pense que j'ai en partie
répondu. Euh, d'abord il y en a
qui ont envie de s'intégrer. Il faut il
y en a. Donc ceux-là, il faut vraiment
les encourager, étendre la main et
cetera. Ceux qui euh sont dans une
logique d'affrontement,
il faut pas baisser les yeux,
il faut traiter faut si si on peut pas
empêcher l'affrontement, il faut traiter
avec l'autorité de l'État, la justice,
voilà la la tout au sens large du mot la
violence légitime de l'État qui existe.
Et euh pour ceux qui sont entre les deux
euh c'est ce dont on vient de parler,
c'est essayer de les séduire. essayer de
les séduire et de leur montrer que il y
a plus d'avantages à vivre selon nos
règles ici que que ne pas les respecter.
Et peut-être aussi rappeler à à ceux qui
qui détestent notre système, même s'ils
sont la nationalité française, que si
vraiment euh ils ne se sentent pas bien,
mais on les retient pas. Ils peuvent
aller vivre euh il y a je crois que
c'est Diams qui est allé vivre en Arabie
Saoudite. Je sais pas si c'est vrai ou
c'est une fake news d'ailleurs. Euh mais
enfin j'avais vu passer ça. Je laisse
les internautes qui nous regardent faire
du fact checking là-dessus. Mais euh
on remercie notre plateforme de fact
checking en direct Capitaine Fact.
C'est c'est donc pour Diams. Moi j'ai
moi j'ai j'ai lu mais peut-être sur un
tweet tout ça donc je garantis pas que
c'était que c'était vrai mais qu'elle
était partie vivre en Arabie Saoudite
bah au moins il c'est cohérent.
Euh autre question internet. Pourrait-on
avoir son avis sur la surveillance de
masse, patriote acte, loi renseignement
française considère-t-il que cet outil
est pertinent pour lutter contre le
terrorisme ?
Alors la loi la loi de 2016, la loi
française c'est pas le patriota acte,
hein, c'est moins que le patriota acte.
Ensuite euh la la loi sur le
renseignement euh moi je l'ai beaucoup
défendu, donc je vais pas je vais pas y
revenir là-dessus. C'est parfait, hein.
Je sais que là, j'ai à supposer que j'ai
une code de popularité en train de
chuter. Euh mais pas mais mais j'assume.
Le on est aujourd'hui dans un dans une
disproportion entre ce que l'État avait
les moyens et surtout le droit de faire
et ce que les gens qui sont dans une
logique offensive ont les les moyens et
là je parle pas de droit de les les
capacités de de faire. Euh c'était
totalement aberrent de voir que nos
services de renseignement étaient
obligés de recourir à des méthodes qui
étaient dans une zone grise juridique
avec parfois un risque juridique pour
les agents eux-mêmes euh alors que il ne
faisait qu'essayer de se mettre à niveau
de de de du danger offensif auquel il
faisait face. Maintenant, je pense qu'il
faut garder des il faut évidemment qu'il
y ait des gardes fous, ils existent. On
entend d'ailleurs certains membres du
service de renseignement dire que
parfois ils sont trop contraignants.
Donc vous voyez comme quoi personne
n'est content. Euh et ce qui est
absolument certain, et là je vais
peut-être remonter un tout petit peu
dans la popularité de de ceux qui de
ceux qui m'ont posé la question en
espérant que que je que que je que je
sois euh complètement contre cette loi.
Ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est
certain, c'est qu'il faut rester
vigilant avec le système démocratique.
Mais vous savez, cette loi, elle offre
des outils, mais il y a déjà de tout un
tas d'outils qui existent. Si euh le le
l'argument qui consiste à dire "Ouais,
mais euh si c'est si c'est un
gouvernement extrémiste qui prend le les
commandes, à ce moment-là, ils ils
auront euh du du ils auront un un prêt à
porter juridique pour pour commettre euh
des enquêtes et et pour persécuter les
gens qui sont pas d'accord
politiquement." Mais attendez, ils ils
se seraient pas gênés de toute façon.
Enfin, je veux dire, on n'est pas dans
un on est on est dans les capacités
technologiques, elles existent. Donc, il
se serait adapté immédiatement. Je pense
alors là vraiment ça c'est un point qui
est vraiment crucial que il faut pas
opposer la sécurité et la liberté.
Pourquoi ? Parce que la liberté
Vous connaissez la dage ?
Bah j'en connais plein. Donc lequel ?
Celui qui dit qu'un peuple qui
Je suis pas d'accord
renonce. Terminez-le.
Ouais c'est qui renonce à sa liberté
pour un peu de sécurité ne mérite ni
l'un ni l'autre. Ouais je
c'est c'est qui ?
C'est Roosevelt. Non. Euh ouais moi je
suis pas du tout d'accord. Je pense que
c'est je pense d'abord que c'était pas
si c'était c'était assez facile à dire à
la place de Roosevelt sans sans vouloir.
Euh vous savez, c'est toujours une
question d'angle quand on dit les
choses.
Moi, je pense qu'aujourd'hui, on est
dans une situation
où la la l'exercice des libertés n'a de
sens que si vous êtes en sécurité. Euh,
on va remonter loin, mais quand l'homme
a commencé à à s'organiser,
vous aviez des des tribus qui se
baladaient et cetera, les gens se sont
rencontrés et soit ils se sont battus,
soit ils se sont mis d'accord pour pour
vivre ensemble. Qu'est-ce qui faisait le
critère ? Qu'est-ce qui faisait que moi,
avec ma tribu, je vais me rapprocher de
toi pour qu'on s'organise ensemble ?
C'est est-ce que moi je serais plus en
sécurité, y compris alimentaire,
sécurité de tout. Est-ce que les miens
seront mieux avec les tiens ou sans les
tiens ? C'est la seule question. Et si
la réponse à cette question c'est oui, à
ce moment-là, on se met ensemble. Donc
c'est la base, le ciment du pacte
social, c'est la sécurité. Les gens
n'accepteront jamais d'aller dans un
univers où ils sont moins en sécurité
pas euh euh par rapport à à la sécurité
qu'ils ont. L'arbitrage, il se fait sur
la sécurité. Je donne un autre exemple.
Je l'ai sorti un type à la dans un débat
à la radio. Il il
C'était Quelle radio ? Quel type ?
Oh, c'était euh c'était Martin Pradel
qui est un copain avocat qui qui a
beaucoup défendu de de djihadiste
et euh qui était très euh très très en
pointe contre je me demande c'était un
moment en 2016 he un débat sur autour de
la loi de renseignement auquel vous
venez de faire allusion et c'était je
veux pas vous dire de bêtises, je sais
plus si c'est sur RFI ou sur France 24,
c'était en tout cas sur une radio
française qui émettait à
l'international. deux organes de
propagande.
Deux organes de propagande et qui
donnaient la la parole à à deux avocats
qui n'étaient pas d'accord comme quoi
même les organes de propagande peuvent
leur mon côté. Euh le euh Martin donc
sur la ligne de Liberty et cetera et
cetera et je et je je lui pose
simplement la question, je lui dis "Mais
attends, attendez, euh si demain
on vous dit "Ouais, c'est vrai, toute
cette sécurité, tout ça, c'est
insupportable et euh on abolit
complètement les contrôles aux
aéroports. Donc euh vous voulez aller
prendre la navette Paris-Marseille
demain matin, bah super, vous y allez.
Au lieu d'arriver 1 heure avant et de
faire tout le contrôle que vous
connaissez et ben c'est dès lors que
vous avez un ticket, on on contrôle rien
et vous passez directement du métro
à la l'enregistrement bagage si vous en
avez et à l'embarquement et bon vol.
Messieurs dames. Est-ce que vous allez
continuer à prendre l'avion ? Ben non,
vous allez arrêter de prendre l'avion
alors que la liberté totale de le
prendre sans entrave vous aura été
accordée. Pourquoi ? parce que vous
allez évidemment vous dire, il y a très
vite un tarêt qui va se dire bah super,
il y a plus de contrôle et donc on va
très vite détourner un avion au départ
d'un aéroport français pour aller le
[__] sur la sur le centreville le plus
proche. Voilà. Et et donc ça montre bien
que si vous avez la liberté absolue mais
sans aucune sécurité, vous vous allez
vous autocensurer sur cette liberté.
Donc ce qu'il faut, alors faut pas
tomber dans l'exemple inverse où on
serait dans un universélien
où une entité toute puissante viendrait
euh assurer une sécurité quasi fétale à
à ses concitoyens en contrepartie d'une
obéissance absolue à à à des règles qui
en réalité seraient complètement
antidémocratiques. Il faut trouver
l'équilibre, vous voyez, je suis lucide,
il faut trouver l'équilibre. Mais en
tout cas, d'opposer systématiquement la
liberté et la sécurité, à mon sens, euh
c'est une erreur profonde parce que l'un
est le préalable de l'autre.
Le fait de de d'avoir une une
surveillance technologique beaucoup plus
importante qu'à votre époque,
qu'à mon époque. C'est dur.
Bah
euh est-ce que ça ça crée pas ça ? Bah
ça ça crée pas une sélection darwinienne
des pires, c'està-dire ce ramassage
scolaire. de du petit islamiste Landa
qui se radicalise rapidement,
qui se fait choper par ses
communications sur son historicité
internet. Est-ce que ça va pas avoir
comme conséquence de sélectionner les
pires, les plus déterminés, les mieux
organisés, ceux qui passent vraiment
sous le radar et capable de faire des
gros cartons ?
Mais ils existent de toute façon.
Euh si vous faites d'abord si vous
faites pas le les les contrôles dont
vous parlez, euh vous allez avoir les
pires qui vont aller récupérer les
médiocres pour en faire leur fantasin.
Donc au lieu d'avoir une armée à x
milliers, vous allez avoir une armée à x
dizaines de milliers.
Il y a combien il y a combien de gens
dangereux fichiers S sur le territoire ?
Alors euh au dernier état du FSPRT qui
est le fichier qui délué hein.
Ouais ouais je sais. Non, non, mais
j'essaie de me souvenir de de parce que
j'ai tellement l'habitude d'un peu
FSPRT, j'essaie bon, le FSPRT, il a été
créé, c'est un fichier unique central
qui a été créé en mars 2015 pour euh y
inscrire les gens euh qui avaient euh
qui étaient radicalisés avec un risque
terroriste islamiste. Parce que vous
savez que les fiches S, c'est atteinte à
la sûreté de l'État. Mais
ceux qui font juste chier, quoi.
Non, non, non. Ce que je veux dire c'est
que S ça veut pas dire islamiste. Vous
avez du S extrême droite, du S extrême
gauche, du S écolo, du S supporter de
foot et du S islamiste. Et j'en oublie
peut-être un ou deux. Donc S atteinte à
la sûreté de l'État, ça n'indique pas la
nature de l'atteinte possible. Le FSPRT,
c'est de l'Islamo. Au FSPRT, le dernier
comptage qui a été révélé par le
ministre de l'intérieur fin septembre,
il est à 20300. Allez, fact checking
pour la dizaine. 20300 en ordre de
grandeur. Dessus, il y a 3300 ou 3400
étrangers
et 700, je suis en ordre de grandeur à
10 15 près, 700 doubles nationaux.
Combien dans les forces de l'ordre ?
Ah, good question.
Vous voulez la réponse officielle ? La
réponse officielle, c'est que il y en a
très peu parce que tout ça est très
surveillé, notamment au moment des
entrées de l'entrée dans
l'administration. Le problème, c'est que
vous avez des gens qui changent et qui
peuvent en entrant ne pas avoir de
conviction extrémistes particulières et
ensuite évoluer. Euh à partir de là, le
on sait pas, on sait pas. Ce que je peux
vous dire, c'est que les Améri ce que
les Américains appellent le blue on blue
ou le green on green qui est l'attentat
par quelqu'un qui porte uniforme contre
ses frères d'armes ou d'uniforme euh et
que qui que malheureusement par exemple
un grand classique en Afghanistan, y
compris d'ailleurs contre des Français
en 2012, contre l'unité de l'armée
française euh qui a caché son famas
après. Non
non, le gars est monté, un gars qui est
monté al je crois qu'ils étaient deux,
il est monté pendant qu'une section de
chasseur alpin faisait fonce son
footing. Il est monté sur sur un
véhicule avec une 762. il a tiré sur la
section qui courait. Donc alors je sais
plus s'ils étaient deux ou pas, mais
c'était des gens qu'ils étaient chargés
d'instruire par ailleurs. Donc le blue
on blue, c'est une des grosses craintes
en France. C'est une vraie grosse
crainte. Et mais pour que ça il y a pas
besoin qu'il soit nombreux pour que la
crainte pour que la crainte existe. Moi
je pense pas qu'il y ait un chiffre
pharamineux. Je pense qu'il y a
effectivement une sorte d'autorégulation
de contrôle mais mais il y en a juste
pour finir sur le FSPRT mes 20000 là euh
ils sont pas tous de de de dangerosité
égale. Vous avez euh et c'est toute la
difficulté de la de du travail du
renseignement c'est de faire de
l'analyse de de degrés de dangerosité.
On n pas les moyens de surveiller tout
le monde malgré les les craintes qui
peut y avoir chez certains des
internautes qui nous regardent.
Aujourd'hui, il y a absolument pas les
moyens de surveiller tout le monde. Donc
le la surveillance 247, la surveillance
24h sur 24, 7 jours sur 7, elle concerne
au mieux ou au pire euh des centaines de
personnes. C'est pas possible plus et
c'est plutôt un petit nombre de
centaines. Donc euh toutes les semaines,
il y a des réunions, je vous explique un
peu la cuisine, il y a des réunions dans
les départements euh des groupes
d'évaluation départementaux où les
représentants de l'autorité de l'État se
réunissent. Donc vous avez le préfet, le
responsable du renseignement
territorial, le responsable de la
sécurité intérieure, le procureur des
responsables de la gendarmerie, de la
police judiciaire, de de des certaines
certaines, je crois qu'il y a des
représentants de de certaines aides
sociales et cetera. Et tous ces gens-là
parlent et font des évaluations
hebdomadaires et font, je caricature,
mais ils font monter ou descendre des
profils en disant tiens lui tiens
qu'est-ce qu'on a sur lui cette semaine
? tiens, on le laisse à moyen ou on le
monte ou on descend un peu et cetera.
Tout ça ensuite est est renvoyé à Paris
et malaxé dans la dans dans dans dans la
matrice et on a et on décide ensuite sur
qui est-ce qu'on laisse les plus gros
dispositifs et qui est-ce qu'on laisse
un peu de côté, sachant que la majorité
des gens font l'objet de sondage. C'est
pendant 3 jours, on les scanne. Mais ça
peut être 3 jours tous les x semaines,
mois et même plus parfois. Vous voyez,
c'est c'est la surveillance 247, elle
est elle est extrêmement rare.
Ça fonctionne pas pour le loup
solitaire, ça.
Ça fonctionne pas pour le type qui va
euh décider tout à coup parce que il
était déjà pas bien mais qu'il va avoir
une rupture dans sa vie.
Genre le scénario de Nanterre.
Exactement. Vous faites allusion jou à
Richardon en en 2002. Alors, je me
souviens plus de ce qu'il a qui fait
péter les plombs, mais c'est un type qui
a une rupture dans sa vie. Euh et euh il
prend son flingue et il va au conseil
municipal de de Nanterre et il fait euh
ce qu'on appellerait aux États-Unis une
tuerie de masse euh donc au sein du
conseil municipal. je me souviens plus
qu'il a déclenché. Mais en tout cas, ça
c'est euh la le gars qui se déclenche
euh c'est quasiment impossible de
l'anticiper. Par contre, ce que vous
répondront les spécialistes du
renseignement, c'est qu'il est
extrêmement rare d'avoir des gens qui se
déclenchent sans qu'il y ait eu des
signaux faibles précurseurs. Et en
réalité, tout le travail des services de
renseignement, c'est d'essayer de
trouver les signaux faibles précurseurs.
Et c'est pour ça que c'est extrêmement
important d'y d'y
associer euh les les élus locaux et les
associations de terrain parce que ce
sont les associations de terrain qui
vont dire au maire tiens là on a un mec
c'est bizarre il a changé d'attitude.
Un chauffeur de bus qui veut pas serrer
la main à une femme c'est un signal
faible ou pas ?
Un chauffeur de bus qui veut pas serrer
la main d'une femme pour moi c'est un
signal faible tout comme un responsable
d'association qui refuse de serrer la
main et de regarder dans les yeux une
ministre sur un plateau de télévision.
C'est un signal faible aussi, peut-être
un peu plus visible. Euh tout ça, c'est
les signaux faibles et vous voyez ce qui
est très pernicieux, c'est qu'on se met
à s'habituer. Il y a il y a du
relativisme en permanence. On dit "Ouais
mais non, mais ça c'est pas grave après
tout machin." Si c'est grave, bien sûr
que ce sont des signaux faibles. Euh
questionnet, quelle politique serait
capable d'appliquer ces solutions ?
Ah voilà, une bonne question. Euh
alors, enf, vous votez quoi ? Mais je je
je vote sans enthousiasme.
Je vote sans enthousiasme.
Euh je pense non mais vous savez à
partir du moment où vous les connaissez,
c'est c'est c'est vachement plus
difficile de voter. Et je pense que
d'ailleurs quand vous les connaissez
pas, il y a des gens aussi qui qui vont
me dire qu'en les connaissant pas, c'est
Mais quand quand on les connaît, on a
envie de les couler dans le béton, c'est
ça ? Non
non, pas tous. Pas tous.
Alors qu'est-ce qui nous reste ? Il nous
reste c'est c'est c'est difficile. Euh
ce que je pense malgré tout,
c'est que l'immense majorité des femmes
et des hommes politiques dont on est
d'accord, enfin en tout cas moi je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure, ils ont compris
l'ampleur du truc et cetera, parfois
avec un prisme de lecture qui est un peu
étroit et mais euh ils sont plus dans
une logique de réaction que d'action.
C'est-à-dire et et vous y avez fait
allusion tout à l'heure dans une de vos
questions euh en disant "Mais est-ce
qu'ils craignent d'être de rester dans
l'histoire comme celui qui aurait et
cetera
Il y a des
il y a des beaucoup je pense de
politiques qui serait prêt à le faire
s'il y avait euh 15 flics qui étaient
tués dans une embuscade à deux endroits
à trois endroits différents.
Euh Ah oui, alors ça c'est encore autre
chose. Ça ça on va y venir après parce
que ça ça c'est un ça c'est un vrai
sujet dans le sujet. Euh là, je parle
juste de de d'une vous savez qu'il y a
des ouvertures de feu quasiment toutes
les nuits en ce moment en France par les
flics et les gendarmes. Euh donc euh un
un des heures qui se dérouleraient un
peu plus mal que d'habitude euh avec des
morts et cetera. Là, peut-être que en
réaction les politiques se diraient "Bon
ben OK, on y va." Mais l'idéal ce serait
d'arriver à d'arriver à à à commencer à
corriger les choses sans que sans
attendre les drames parce que comme je
disais tout à l'heure avec Close Vit ou
Sunsu mais en tout cas il vaut mieux il
vaut mieux être à l'initiative des
choses qu'on a bien préparé qu'on a
planifié et et ne pas se faire
surprendre. Or si on était dans un dans
un engrenage suite à un drame on serait
nécessairement dans la réaction et donc
dans la surprise et donc forcément ça se
passerait moins bien ou encore plus mal.
Donc ça me donne pas des politiques.
Quelle politique pour vous ? Droite,
gauche, centre.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a c'est
plus c'est plus tellement droite, gauche
ou centre. C'est les gens qui ont
compris et les gens qui ont pas compris.
C'est une ligne transversale. Al
qui a compris ?
Euh chez les gens qui ont clairement
compris, vous avez euh de que je connais
hein, vous avez alors à gauche CAS9
Vals. Euh
ils sont à gauche eux. Ah bah écoutez en
tout cas aux dernières nouvelles, ils
étaient il ils ont ils ont appartenu il
est en Espagne, on entend plus parler.
Il fait sa campagne payé avec nos notre
pognon. Donc vous avez euh Gérard Colomb
puisqu'il l'a dit à la France entière
euh lui. Non,
vous avez écouté en tout cas là il y a
eu un je pense pas et en tout cas là
c'était c'était lucide.
C'était lucide. Oui oui oui. Non mais
j'ai compris mais je je
je là c'était en tout cas un éclair de
lucidité. Euh
je pense que le président Macron a
compris mais que le président Macron est
dans une logique euh qui est de dire que
l'économie réglera le problème et que il
voilà c'est j'arrive pas j'arrive
j'arrive pas à bien cerner Emmanuel
Macron sur le sujet mais en tout cas il
a enfin il a très clairement compris sur
les questions de sécurité qui avait qu'
avait un problème ça ça c'est certain à
droite des gens comme leur voqua Valérie
PCres que souvent on oppose. Ils ont
compris. Si vous parlez avec eux, ça
c'est certain
ils ont compris parce que ça fait voter.
Non mais quand il quand il quand quand
vous quand vous discutez avec eux c'est
il s'agit pas de faire voter et c'est
c'est de voyez le le il y a quelques
années il y en a qui me disaient non
mais attends tu exagères tues paranoles
machin et tout voilà aujourd'hui non
tu de votre bouquin de 2015 c'était quoi
c'était
Ouais ouais le sursaut ou le chaos ?
Ouais, quand j'ai écrit le sursaut
édition aux éditions
plomb, c'était plomb. Quand j'ai écrit
ce bouquin,
c'est bien écrit hein.
Bah écoutez, ça c'est pas à moi de le
dire.
Ils sont ils sont plombs dans ce
Oui, d'ailleurs, j'ai reçu j'ai reçu une
menace de mort parmi parmi celle que je
reçois. J'en ai reçu une assez amusante.
Enfin amusante, ça fait pas toujours
rire, mais qui était un gars qui sur
Twitter m'a alors que je je j'indiquais
la sortie du livre, il m'a répondu plomb
PLB. ogation. Donc enfin c'est vrai que
c'était facile. Euh mais sinon euh non,
il y a eu il y a eu une vraie il y a eu
une vraie évolution. Je vous donne un
exemple parmi 1000 en juin en juin ou
juillet, je sais plus. Enfin, en tout
cas, au début de l'été 2014,
je suis sur un plateau télé sur une
chaîne d'info, je me souviens plus
laquelle et j'explique, on est un peu
après l'attaque du musée juif de
Bruxelles qui est fin mai et j'explique
que compte tenu de tout un tas de choses
que j'argumente, il est inéluctable
qu'il y ait des attaques à la
Kalashnikov sur nos concitoyens dans les
rues françaises dans les 12 mois qui
viennent. Et je sors ça un matin au
petit déj devant les gens qui nous
reviennent. Et je lis dans les yeux,
c'est en direct et je lis dans les yeux
des deux journalistes qui m'interrogent
un effroi commun et ils se disent, je
les vois, je vois dans leurs yeux, ils
se disent "Putain, le mec a pété les
plombs, on a un mec qui vient de fondre
les plombs en direct à l'antenne." Bon,
alors bon, ils font comme si j'avais pas
dit ce que je venais de dire et on parle
d'autres choses. Bon, tout ça, c'est des
exemples de de c'est des choses que j'ai
vécu pendant tous les les deux derniers
trimestres 2014. Moi, je sais que ça va
arriver. Je le sais comme tous les gens
qui travaillent sur ce sujet parce que
c'est inéluctable parce que
attentat pendant les solds pendant les
fêtes de Noël
voilà on sait on sait que ça va arriver.
Euh en en septembre 2014, Alad Nani qui
était le porte-parole, le monsieur le
Gbels, certains l'ont appelé le Gbels de
l'État islamique euh fait une grande
déclaration contre contre la France qui
qui a comme ce qui est d'ailleurs fou
comme effet qui a comme effet
d'interrompre l'agenda du ministre de
l'intérieur qui était Bernard Kazne qui
va sur le péron de de de l'hôtel Bova
pour faire pour faire une déclaration
sur le thème nous n'avons pas peur ce
qui est quand même ça montre quand même
le le degré de de de de de tension sur
le sur le sujet Et malgré ça, vous avez
tout un tas de gens qui considéraient
que non, tout ça a était très exagéré.
Il y a une scène extraordinaire, si vous
les regarder, euh de de Marc Trévidic
qui est un juge qui connaît
particulièrement bien ces questions, euh
Marc Trévidic avec qui j'ai écrit des
articles et cetera que je connais bien,
que que j'apprécie énormément, avec qui
je suis pas d'accord surtout mais qu'
alors là lui vraiment c'est quelqu'un
qui qui connaît le sujet. Bon, Marc
Trévid qui est sur un plateau, je crois,
chez Tadei et il est avec William
Bourdon notamment qui est un des un des
avocats.
Total
Oui, alors est avocat de Je sais pas, il
est avocat total.
Non, non, contre Total
et il est beaucoup avocat des
islamistes. Bon et euh il est bourdon
avec une morgue, il faut bien le dire ce
soir-là, assez odieuse. Je j'invite ceux
qui s'intéressent à aller retrouver ça
sur Il y a c'est facile à trouver. euh
renvoie Trévidic dans ses buts alors que
Trévidic euh explique pourquoi la France
va nécessairement être frappé dans les
mois qui viennent. Et euh Bourdon lui
dit "Mais c'est pas vrai, c'est des
conneries et cetera." Bon voilà, donc on
a un niveau et Bourdon est un avocat
connu qui qui qui qui a qui qui est
inséré dans le système.
Bon donc c'est j'ai fait beaucoup de
débats depuis 3 ans avec lui sur ces
questions. Al c'était toujours lui qu'on
me sortait pour les tenant la liberté
contre l'oppression que j'étais changé
censé représenter. Enfin bon euh mais il
y avait un scepticisme il y avait quand
même un grand scepticisme. Et puis quand
c'est arrivé bah forcément le regard a
changé. Les gens ont dit "Ah bah vous
vous étiez quelques-uns, vous aviez
raison." Il y a pas de gloire à tirer
avoir eu raison. Simplement on a bossé.
On a bossé. Vous savez Peggy Peggy dit
une chose, il dit Charles dit beaucoup
de choses formidables hein. Une pensée
quand même tombée au champ d'honneur le
5 septembre 1914 he puisque c'est quand
même le le le il faut toujours s'en
souvenir mais en ce moment plus que
jamais. Euh et parmi les merveilles
qu'il a eu l'occasion d'écrire avant, il
a eu cette phrase, il dit "Il faut dire
ce que l'on voit mais surtout il faut
voir ce que l'on voit." Donc il faut
avoir la avant de décrire, il faut déjà
avoir la capacité de voir. Et pour ça,
il faut bosser, il faut enlever les
œillères, il faut se dire "Bah ouais,
tout peut arriver, tout peut arriver.
Est-ce que il y a des choses
même des choses qui sont jamais arrivées
à l'échelle de notre génération qui sont
même jamais arrivé à l'échelle de la
génération de nos parents ?
Ça peut arriver. Voilà. C'est déjà
arrivé dans l'histoire. L'histoire est
tragique. L'histoire est tragique. Au
nom de quoi est-ce que la Au nom de quoi
est-ce que euh la la France en 2018
serait épargnée par le tragique de
l'histoire, la France et l'Europe ? Ça
fait on n' jamais eu 70 ans sans guerre.
Donc pourvu que ça dure, mais ça ça ne
va pas nécessairement durer juste parce
que c'est comme ça ou juste parce qu'on
est béni. Ça c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche. Donc donc les les politiques
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus qu'il y a 3
ans commencent à commencent à comence
façon ils vont s'en emparer dans pas
très longtemps. Euh ils vont tous bien
le prendre à mon avis ça va bien. Ils
vont être tous mis au parfum. Et euh
les banlieux, l'immigration, des mots à
dire là-dessus ?
Bah les banlieux là on en a quand même
pas mal parlé. immigration.
Euh oui oui bien sûr. Euh l'immigration
qui a été extrêmement mal gérée depuis
40 ans, c'est un des c'est un des
facteurs principaux qui nous a qui nous
a amené là où on est aujourd'hui. On a
il y a un déséquilibre démographique,
enfin pas démographique, il y a un
déséquilibre de population aujourd'hui
en Europe. Euh c'est pas vrai que la
question des équilibres est une fausse
question. Tout ne se vaut pas. tout le
monde ne peut pas vivre sans sans aucune
autre considération que que l'amour de
l'être humain les uns avec les autres.
Ça ça n'est pas vrai. Ça a jamais été
vrai dans l'histoire de l'humanité. Il y
a pas de raison que ce soit vrai
aujourd'hui. Il y a eu une erreur
monumentale qui a été faite à la base
qui est le regroupement familial dans
les années 70. Euh
il fallait bien faire du bâtiment hein.
On était mais on était pas obligé de
faire venir les femmes et les enfants.
Alors vous allez me dire "Ouais mais ça
c'est dégueulasse salot machin et
cetera." Mais au nom de quoi ? Pourquoi
on fait on fait des contrats courts, on
les gens bossent, il y aura toujours des
volontaires pour venir bosser parce
qu'il y a du travail et
faire baisser les salaires.
Oui,
je fais l'avocat du diable.
Mais non, mais vous avez raison. Mais
mais au nom de quoi est-ce que la au nom
de quoi est-ce que le l'ouverture de
l'ouverture inconsidérée fait baisser
les salaires ? Si vous avez toujours une
demande de gens pour venir, vous pouvez
faire une rotation, les gens peuvent
faire 5 ans, on peut être ferme. Je veux
dire, on a on a il y a pas dès qu'il
s'agit d'immigration, on a l'impression
qu'il y a une espèce de d'ou case et que
et juste il faut être sympa et ah les
pauvres. Mais non, enfin je veux dire,
on a des règles, on a des on a une les
les dirigeants qui ont une politique à
mener avec des citoyens qui votent pour
eux qui sont les les citoyens de la
République française et les citoyens de
chacun des pays européens. Et et au nom
de quoi est-ce que il faudrait juste
accueillir pour accueillir
parce qu'on a un peu massacré leur pays
qu'on s'est gavé chez supposer à
supposer. Je veux pas aller sur ce
terrain polémique, je vois que je ça
vous fait marrer non, je vais pas y
aller. Je je vais juste vous dire à
supposer même à supposer même que que
que je dise OK c'est vrai machin. à
supposer même ma réponse serait beaucoup
plus nuancée mais à supposer même. Et
alors ?
Et alors est-ce que est-ce que parce que
il y aurait et encore une fois elle a
supposé une dette passée, un mauvais
comportement passé euh il faudrait ce
serait open bar et on renoncerait à nos
lois. Mais je mets absolument pas. On a
fait l'erreur. Il y a eu une l'erreur,
on va pas refaire les 40 dernières
années. Euh il y a il y en a eu, moi
j'en vois deux majeurs. La première
c'est que dans en France et la deuxième
européenne en France on a euh donc
regroupement familial. OK. Mais en
France, on a abandonné le sujet de
l'autorité, l'identité à l'extrême
droite. Et donc pendant 30 ans, mais ça
c'est le c'est un coup de génie
maavellélique de Méron. Bien sûr,
pendant 30 ans, si vous commenciez à
voir le le début, l'ombre du début de ce
que je suis en train de dire, vous étiez
fachaud direct. Là, heureusement, ça a
un peu changé, mais vous étiez faud
direct.
Donc la droite la droite républicaine,
RPR et cetera qui soit dit en passant
quand vous lisez leur programme, il
était vachement plus à droite que la
droite d'aujourd'hui, mais bon, c'est un
autre sujet. le le ils étaient quand
même très gênés aux entournures parce
que il y avait le point au-delà duquel
il fallait pas aller et on est allé sur
des lignes que tout se vaut euh que
toutes les valeurs se vaut, tout se vaut
et ça mais non tout se vaut pas. Tout se
vaut pas. Si vous allez dans un pays
musulman et vous demandez à aller à la
messe, vous allez vite vous rendre
compte que tout ne se vaut pas. Donc euh
on est euh on est dans des on est de de
de là, on a c'était la première erreur.
Donc on a laissé s'installer euh pas
manque d'autorité et cetera. Enfin bon,
on va pas recommencer. Et la deuxième
erreur qui est là est une erreur
actuelle et qui est une erreur qu'on a
pas fini de payer, c'est que vous savez
quand vous quand vous quand vous avez
des règles, si celui qui est chargé dans
de les édicter et par extension d'en
veiller à l'exécution, c'estàdire
l'exécutif euh annonce à l'avance qu'il
n'appliquera pas sa règle, bah c'est
fini. C'estàd que la règle, c'est comme
si elle existait pas. En en août 2015,
on laisse rentrer massivement, on va
faire en grande masse, massif,
1 million de personnes
en Europe,
en Europe quelques en quelques semaines
euh par le donc par la Turquie, la Grèce
l'Italie
après l'Italie mais d'abord la Turquie,
la Grèce dans mon livre mon livre donc
vous sur le chaos, je vous ai dit vous
en vous avez la gentillesse d'en parler
tout à l'heure, je l'écris, je je le
rends à l'éditeur le 31 mars 2015 et
dedans, j'écris un truc, j'ai vu passer
C'est une note des services de
renseignement italien citée par un
journal italien source ouverte tout va
bien je la cite et dedans je mets parmi
les scénarios risqués pour l'avenir que
les islamistes avaient annoncé que ils
allaient favoriser euh la
déstabilisation de l'Europe par l'entrée
massive de centaines de milliers de
réfugiés fin août. Fin août, c'est
marqué. D'accord. Bon, qu'est-ce qui se
passe fin août ? Ce que les mecs avaient
dit, c'est quand même intéressant.
Ensuite, on fait rentrer des gens dont
aujourd'hui on sait que ou plusement on
sait que on a pu vérifier, on a pu
prendre les empreintes et cetera. Je
parle même pas de vérifier les identités
mais au moins avoir des éléments pour
les suivre que de l'ordre de 10 %. Donc
sur en base 1 million, on a identifié
que 100000 personnes. Les autres sont
là. D'accord ? Ensuite l'erreur donc la
première erreur c'est d'avoir dit que
qu'on appliquerait pas notre loi Merkel
qui dit Vircha Funda et tous ce truc
qu'on a pas fini de payer. Ça je peux
vous dire pouvez garder l'enregistrement
on n pas fini de le payer. Derrière tout
ça euh on a commis en plus l'erreur de
penser que parce qu'une partie je dis
bien une partie de ces gens avaient
effectivement souffert de la guerre les
autres étant des de l'opportunisme et de
l'immigration économique et celle-là il
y a aucune raison de la tolérer en
dehors de l'immigration choisie. les
gens qui étaient dans une logique de
d'asile et donc de refuge et il y a une
tradition qu'il s'agit pas de changer
sur l'asile. Peut-être ces conditions
mais ça le principe non. On a pensé que
parce qu'ils fuyaent les horreurs d'une
guerre, ils allaient venir ici en Europe
bien sûr pour avoir une sécurité mais
aussi qu'ils allaient accepter les
règles de vie en Europe. Mais mais mais
non, pas forcément. Pas forcément. et
vous avez une explosion, et je pèse mes
mots des des des crimes sexuels qui sont
commis notamment en Italie et en
Allemagne par des gens qui sont rentrés
ces trois dernières années dans des
proportions bien supérieures à avant et
qui sont au moins en partie
l'illustration précise de du fait que il
y a des il y a des il y a des coutumes
et des modes de vie que les que les gens
qui sont rentrés n'ont pas l'intention
d'abandonner.
On va passer à un autre sujet. à la fois
connecté, pas connecté. Question
d'internet qui va nous lancer sur la
légitime défense.
Allez.
Que pensez-vous du port d'armes
dissimulé pour lutter contre le
terrorisme lors d'attaque sur le
territoire français ?
Alors euh celui qui a posé la question
connaît la réponse. Peut-être que tout
le monde ne la connaît pas. Je fais
partie des J'ai écrit dans mon livre et
je fais partie des gens qui prôent
depuis longtemps une augmentation
significative du nombre de gens armés en
civil. D'abord pourquoi et ensuite
jusqu'où ? Pourquoi on sait, alors là,
je peux vous donner euh encore des
milliers d'exemples que face à une
attaque, là on est dans l'hypothèse de
l'attaque qui se déroule, d'accord, soit
par un soit par un véhicule bélier, soit
avec des armes à feu. Face à une attaque
qui se déroule, queles que soient les
motivations de l'auteur, peu importe. La
seule façon d'y mettre fin, c'est le
feu. Il y a que le feu qui arrête le
feu. On va pas avec un mégaphone en
disant arrête machin. Si on est dans une
phase active de tir, je parle pas de
prise d'otage, pas forcément mais de
tir, il y a que le il y a que le feu qui
peut arrêter le feu. Donc une fois qu'on
a fait ce constat, plus le feu dure,
plus il y a de mort. Donc il faut qu'il
y ait un feu de repost le plus
rapidement possible. Donc pour ça, il
faut mailler le territoire avec des gens
capables de reposter. Comment on fait ?
on dit on fait des patrouilles de
police, gendarmerie, sentinelle. Très
bien. Ça c'est des gens qui qui arrivent
mais qui sont pas sur place. La seule
façon de faire baisser le le la la durée
d'attente pour riposter, c'est de
mailler le territoire avec des gens en
civil qui ont les compétences pour
porter une arme. Comment on y arrive ?
D'abord et ça c'est un point sur lequel
avec d'autres et avec les syndicats de
police mais j'ai beaucoup pesé en 2015-2
2016 pour que les policiers et les
gendarmes, donc les gens qui sont
habilités à porter une arme puissent la
porter hors service. Un type qui bosse
de 8h à 18h avec une arme à 18h30, il
est tout autant capable de l'utiliser
qu'à 17h30. D'accord ? Premièrement,
donc on a fini par y arriver.
J'ai j'ai aidé le le groupe LR au Sénat
la semaine dernière à à rédiger un texte
qui a été déposé euh en cours de semaine
pour pour obliger les établissements
privés recevant du public, salle de
concert, euh stade et cetera, à laisser
rentrer armé les gens qui ont le droit
de porter une arme. Parce qu'aujourd'hui
il y a un truc totalement sidérant,
c'est que vous avez des ça dépend en
fait des propriétaires de salle et que
vous avez des gens qui considèrent que
je cite "Les armes c'est dangereux".
Donc y compris l'arme du gentil qui va
éventuellement défendre tout le monde
contre un méchant qui arriverait mais
non c'est dangereux. Donc on interdit
aux policiers qui ont le droit d'être
armé de venir avec leur arme au
spectacle. Ce qui a un triple effet
négatif. D'abord le policier, il peut
être visé chez lui. C'est pour ça aussi
que le por d'arm était donné leur
service et on a bien vu à Mananville
avec des gens qui attendent les
policiers et je vous disais tout à
l'heure au moins sep attaques depuis
depuis juin contre des policiers hors
service. Donc faut qu'ils puissent se
défendre en rentrant chez eux. Deux dans
les transports en commun, il faut que
les que les gens puissent intervenir et
des gens armés dans les transports en
commun sont potentiellement des sauveurs
de vie. D'ailleurs, la raison pour
laquelle Valérie PCRES a accordé le le
le les titres de transport gratuit en
Île-de-France pour les policiers et les
gendarres. C'est la raison pour laquelle
elle l'a fait. Et comme quoi, vous
voyez, les politiques peuvent avoir des
des idées concrètes sur le sujet. Euh et
euh troisièmement, évidemment, la
troisème vertu, c'est sur place s'il y a
une attaque. Bon, donc on verra ce que
cette proposition de loi devient mais il
faut c'est dans la cohérence du port
d'arme hors service. Donc ça ça nous met
sur les personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique.
Professeurs des écoles, on les arme ?
Non, les les professeurs de l'école, on
les arme pas. Mais par contre, on peut
tout à fait imaginer que vous ayez un
membre de l'équipe euh dans dans l'école
qui appartiennent à et là, je vais venir
à ma deuxième idée et c'est là qu'on
peut faire la la connexion. Moi, je
milite pour mais je l'ai dit écrit, j'ai
fait un papier dans le Figaro là-dessus
et tout pour que au sein de la garde
républicaine qui existe aujourd'hui, la
garde républicaine c'est une coquille
vide. Enfin, ça
républicaine, le mec qui s'est désingué
dans le jardin de l'Élysée là. Non,
non, non, non, non, non, non, pardon,
pardon. Lapsus, la garde nationale, vous
avez raison. Pardon,
avec son arme de service.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, j'ai vu ça. La la
garde national,
c'est un geste fort, non ?
Oui. Qui qui était mais qui faisait écho
aussi à une lettre de plus de de plus de
20 pages anonymes qui avait été écrite
par Non, 27 pages, j'ai j'ai me souviens
plus. Enfin, ouais. De récrimination sur
les conditions d'emploi et cetera. Bien
sûr que c'est un geste fort. D'ailleurs,
le nombre de suicides au sein de l'armée
de de la police et de la gendarmerie est
est aussi un geste fort. On y reviendra
dans un instance si vous voulez parce
que j'ai j'ai une idée là-dessus, mais
je finis juste sur le sur le port
d'armes.
Euh aujourd'hui, d'abord, il faut donner
ce port d'arme hors service à d'autres
services de l'État. Les gens qui sont
armés, les douiniers à Ber sont
tétanisés, ils disent non, c'est
dangereux. le le le l'ennemi euh qui
considère que le que ce qu'il faut
dégommer c'est du bleu du bleu force de
l'ordre, il va pas faire la différence
hein le moi j'ai des copains douigners
qui m'ont raconté qu'ils habitent dans
des HLM et ils son on les appelle le
flic. On dit pas "Ah oui mais non je
suis pas flic, je suis douigé." Non non
il y a une unité de d'appartenance dans
dans les yeux de l'ennemi à à à aux
forces régaliennes. Donc il faut que
tous les gens qui sont formés et qui ont
le droit de porter une arme en service
puissent la porter hors service. Ensuite
il faut favoriser leur circulation, leur
accès au site. On vient d'en parler. Et
à côté de ça, la euh la garde nationale,
hein, pas mon lapsus de tout à l'heure,
la garde nationale qui existe, qui est
une coquille plus ou moins vide, il faut
y faire rentrer des gens qui son à mon
avis, il faut plus quelques centaines de
milliers de personnes qui seraient
composés d'abord par priorité par les
anciens des services régaliens de
l'État. un ancien policier euh qui est
dès lors qu'il n'a pas de de problèmes
physiques ni psychologique euh il peut
tout à fait continuer à porter une arme.
Le gars, c'est pas parce que vous avez
55 ans. Si vous avez porté une arme
pendant 25 ans, vous pouvez la porter
quelques années de plus premièrement.
Deuxièmement, vous vous ouvrez ce droit
à un certain nombre de civils qui sont
volontaires. Alors là, on va me dire "Ah
ouais, mais non, mais ça c'est dangereux
tout ça parce qu'il y a une
méconnaissance totale sur ce que c'est
que les armes en France." Mais pour
combattre l'argument, il faut pas aller
faire de de prêcher et remonter des
courants historiques lourds de de
mouvement anti-arme en France parce que
les gens n'y connaissent beaucoup de
Français ne et en particulier de
journalistes et ça ne savent pas n'ont
jamais vraiment réfléchi à ces
questions.
Les chasseurs, on les laisse armer.
Il faut il faut juste je finis juste, il
faut juste se souvenir que aujourd'hui
en France au sein de l'opération
Sentinelle sur tous les mecs que vous
voyez patrouiller en vert, il y en a 20
% qui sont des civils et qui sont des
réservistes et qui font moins de 20
jours par an. Donc ces gens-là, on on
considère qu'ils sont assez bien formés
pour porter non pas un pistolet, mais un
fusil d'assaut d'un colibre bien
supérieur. Et ça marche puisque à la
garere Saint-Charles à Marseille le 1er
octobre 2017, un un islamiste étranger
en situation irrégulière qui avait été
relâché de son centre de rétention
égorge deux jeunes filles cousines et et
se fait tout de suite abattre par
un groupe de de sentinelle et celui qui
a tiré c'est un réserviste. Donc au nom
de quoi est-ce que ce qu'il est ce qui
est possible dans un cadre militaire en
uniforme ne serait pas possible dans un
cadre militaire puisque la garde
nationale c'est militaire en civil. Je
je dis juste que je pense qu'il faudra
arriver à ça. Euh et on aurait à ce
moment-là un maillage. On aurait euh
quelqu allez allez on va dire en grande
masse 5 à 600000 personnes en prenant
euh les anciens, les hors services et
cetera, plus ces civils dont je parle et
on aurait euh allez une 500000 personnes
armées et on couvre et on couvre le
territoire comme est-ce que est-ce qu'on
utilise les chasseurs comme auxiliaire ?
Bah comme auxiliaire, qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire ? Euh, ils ont ils sont
autorisés à porter une arme. Euh
Oui, mais attendez, c'est pas parce que
vous êtes euh que vous avez un permis de
de chasse et que vous savez tirer au
calibre 12 que vous savez tirer avec un
pistolet de 9 mm en porte discret, hein.
C'est ça n'a littéralement rien à voir.
Donc euh
c'est un peu comme un un sanglier, un
VTT, non ?
D'accord.
C'est hallucinant histoire. Ouais, on
est d'accord. Et juste pour finir donc
vos profs à l'école, on peut tout à fait
imaginer et c'est la réponse à votre
question que un membre formé appartenant
à la garde nationale qui a été checké
exactement comme un candidat policier ou
gendarme évalué physiquement évalué
psychologiquement et qui s'entraîne
régulièrement puisse porter une arme sur
lui dès lors qu'il appartient à cette
unité militaire réserviste.
Une parenthèse les suicides par arme à
feu dans les forces de l'
Ouais très intéressant dramatique à mon
sensation. Ouais. À mon forte
augmentation et à mon sens, alors il y a
sans doute plein de facteurs mais l'un
des facteurs c'est que
Alouri qui est un le théoricien du 3e
djihad a écrit en 2005 que pour vaincre
le le géant qui est l'Occident, il
fallait
démobiliser
les 1000 en taille. Bah c'était la
stratégie des 1000 en tailles.
C'est-à-dire que si vous faire tomber un
géant et que vous n'avez pas de moyens,
vous le saignez par 1000 petites
entailles et il va finir par se viser de
son ch de son sang et de ses forces.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe pour nos forces
de sécurité intérieure depuis 2015 ?
Elles sont soumises à des tensions
permanentes. Il y a énormément de mal à
avoir les périodes de repos, les
périodes de formation et cetera. Les
gens sont en stress en permanence.
Depuis 2016, ils ont compris queils
pouvaient être individuellement pris à
partie tout le temps et il suffit que ça
arrive une fois tous les 3 mois pour que
ça terrorise tout le monde. Quand je dis
terroriser, ça les paralyse pas mais
c'est un stress. À chaque fois qu'une
patrouille de police sort aujourd'hui, à
chaque fois qu'une patrouille de police
sort aujourd'hui, ceux qui la composent
se demandent ce qui va leur arriver. 99
fois sur 100, il leur arrive rien mais
ça ronge. Et donc ce stress, c cette
tension permanente au sein de nos forces
de sécurité intérieure qui est notamment
générée par la situation sécuritaire
depuis 2015 et ben elle aboutit
aujourd'hui à ce que ça craque ça ça ça
se tend ça craque. Il y a des gens qui
suicident évidemment avec d'autres
problèmes qui viennent se superposer
là-dessus mais la la structure est très
est très entamée par cette histoire.
Une petite question pour vous
déconcentrer un peu pour ou contre la
torture ? Alors, je pense que la torture
ça marche pas.
Est-ce qu'on doit être pire ?
Je suis pas le premier à le dire.
Est-ce qu'on doit être plus bourreaux
que les bourreaux ?
Non, moi je pense que la démocratie a le
droit de se défendre. C'est pas une
manière de répondre sur la torture.
La légitime défense.
Non non non mais la légitime défense
c'est face à une attaque. Donc c'est pas
le le on peut imaginer d'ailleurs le
président Hollande vous y faisiez
allusion. Il a en a parlé dans son dans
le livre d'entretien avec les
journalistes. Aller les exécutions
[Musique]
extrajudiciaire
à l'étranger et cetera. Alors là moi
j'ai aucun problème avec ça. Vraiment ça
je pense que la démocratie a le droit de
se défendre. La torture,
elle a le droit de se défendre dans le
cadre de la loi.
Elle a le droit de se défendre dans le
cadre de la loi. Bien sûr.
Là, si c'est extrajudicien, on fait quoi
?
Non, mais c'est c'est sur des c'est dans
le cadre de missions euh qui sont des
des des missions de d'ordre militaire
ordonné par l'exécutif. Il y a pas
l'ombre d'un problème. C'est militaire.
Pas de juge, pas de de rien.
C'est militaire quand vous faites, c'est
militaire. C'est c'est il y a un cadre
qui est le cadre précis de d'emploi des
des des forces armées. Donc donc c'est
légal. Il y a pas de débat là-dessus.
le terrorisme le terrorisme la torture
pour les terroristes. Euh je pense que
euh de ce que de ce qu'on lit sur
Guantanamo, sur les sur ce qui a pu euh
sur les les résultats que les Américains
ont pu avoir, euh je pense que ça ne je
pense que ça ne marche pas. Voilà. Donc
à partir de là, la question est évacuée.
Je pense, je vais même vous dire plus
loin, je pense que on obtient bien plus
euh alors ça prend peut-être un peu plus
de temps que si parce que quand vous
torturez quelqu'un, le mec va vous
raconter n'importe quoi pour que ça
s'arrête. Donc on peut avoir Ouais. mais
on peut avoir beaucoup plus de résultats
en traitant bien quelqu'un, notamment si
c'est quelqu'un d'un peu éduqué, un
chef, un cadre et cetera, en le faisant
euh en le faisant parler dans une enfin
ça peut ça peut ça peut mieux marcher.
Et là, c'est pas mon expérience
personnelle qui parle puisque j'en sais
rien personnellement, mais enfin on a
quand même beaucoup parlé. C'est des
sujets de conversation que j'ai de façon
récurrente et de chez les gens qui dont
c'est le métier, il y a assez peu de
gens qui sont favorables à la torture, à
la bourrin quoi.
Ben, on arrête les carrés de sucre.
C'est ça. Vous connaissez les carrés de
sucre ? Je connais les carrés de sucre,
je connais la Je connais la musique, je
connais la lumière. Voilà, c'est des
la baguette racise.
C'est la Non, ça je connais pas.
Ah, on va vous montrer. Et euh bon,
revenons à nos à des sujets plus
sérieux. Euh euh la légitime défense.
Oui.
On en est où en France ? Alors, en
France, on a une loi qui a évolué en par
la loi a enfin évolué euh par une loi de
février 2017. Euh
et on a une loi, je vais peut-être vous
surprendre. Alors donc ça c'est vraiment
un de mes sujets professionnels de
prédilection euh et euh je j'enseigne
dans les écoles de police. Enfin
vraiment ça, je je suis les deux mains
dedans. Euh
on a un texte qui est pas mal du tout.
On a juste une difficulté majeure, c'est
d'une part euh surmonter les réticences
juridiques des opérateurs de terrain qui
sont conditionnés par 40 années
épouvantables où la seule chose qu'on
disait c'est ne sors pas ton flingue
sinon c'est les emmerdes assurés.
Des papiers.
Ouais. Des papiers dans des papiers dans
le meilleur des cas.
Et deuxièmement euh beaucoup de
magistrats, pas tous mais beaucoup de
magistrats qui ne se rendent pas du tout
compte de ce que c'est
opérationnellement que une scène de
combat. Parce que la légitime défense,
ça devient une question de droit mais à
la base dans la sur le terrain, c'est
une c'est une scène de combat,
c'est-à-dire c'est l'exposition de
l'agent à un risque de mort imminent.
Comme à la guerre, c'est pareil, ça fait
sur le cerveau le même effet. D'accord ?
Ensuite, on calque du droit, mais c'est
une scène de de de combat. Je vous donne
un exemple. Parmi 1000, à chaque fois
que je défends quelqu'un qui est utilisé
pour l'usage de l'arme, on lui pose la
question parmi plein de questions.
Pourquoi vous avez tiré 5 6 7 fois et
cetera ? D'abord le d'abord on lui dit
combien combien de fois vous avez tiré ?
Le gars répond je sais pas. Quasiment
personne ne sait combien de coups de feu
on tire dans une dans dans une scène de
de dans une scène de combat. D'accord.
Euh ensuite
problématique quand même.
Non, c'est pas problématique. C'est
c'est juste normal combat. On sait pas
combien il reste dans le magasin.
Ah oui, non mais c'est pas avoir des
problèmes tactiques. C'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que si vous voulez faire une
parenthèse tactique, moi j'y vais bien
volonté, c'est que dès que vous avez une
acalmie au feu, il faut changer de
chargeur
en gardant le précédent. Comme ça, quand
on a plus rien, on voit ce qui reste
mais comme ça, on risque pas de se faire
surprendre. Bon, mais restons sur le
droit. Les juges disent combien de coups
de feu vous avez tiré ? Réponse, je sais
pas. Ensuite, pourquoi vous avez tiré
ensuite ? Alors le l'enquête établie que
vous avez tiré sep fois. Pourquoi ? Mais
parce que quand vous prenez une une arme
semi-automatique, vous tirez sep fois.
Il faut entre une seconde 2 et une
seconde 5 si on est un bon tireur pour
tirer sep fois. Donc le le ensuite vous
avez la puissance d'arrêt des munitions.
Le pistolet standard aujourd'hui en
service dans les armées dans les dans
les polices occidentales, c'est le 9 mm.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il y a une synthèse
qui est faite entre la capacité de
stoppage euh et le risque de pour les
civils derrière et puis aussi un coût de
fabrication. Donc on s'est mis d'accord
grosso modo les Américains peuvent alors
pardon va être technique les certains
américains servicent certains services
américains utilise le 40 ou le 45 mais
en gros dans le monde entier on est il y
a une quasi unanimité sur le 9 mm le 9
mm n'a pas de puissance d'arrêt. Je vais
vous donner juste un exemple parmi des
dizaines. Attentat des Champs-Élysées.
Le jeudi 20 février 2017, le dénommé
Karim Shurfy attaque un camion de de
policiers qui est en sécurisation de de
d'un centre turc sur les Champs-Élysées.
Le chef du groupe va prendre une
décision qui va sauver la vie de la
plupart de ses équipiers. Chef du groupe
policier, c'est que face au risque
d'attentat, il ne laisse que deux
policiers dans le camion pour dîner
parce que c'est l'heure du dîner. Et les
quatre autres, ils disent "On va se on
se met sur la voie publique et on se
colle pas les uns aux autres". pour pas
faire une cible pas mal quand même. Shfy
arrive, il tue euh le le malheureux
Xavier jugelé et il tire dans la foulée
sur le deuxième qui était en train de
dîner qui va être grièvement blessé et
il fait le tour du véhicule. les les
policiers sur le trottoir ne le voient
pas parce qu'il s'est garé contre le
contre le véhicule policier côté
chaussée.
Il fait le tour, lui-même ne les a pas
vu et quand il arrive, il fait le tour
de la du véhicule de police pour pour
achever hein, il a le l'alarme comme ça
pour achever le policier blessé qui est
en train de ramper. Et quand il arrive
au coin de la du camion de police, il
voit les quatre policiers alignés à une
vingtaine de mètres et les quatre
policiers témoignent de ce que dans la
dans les yeux du gars, il y a une grande
surprise. Et en fait, il y a une
surprise réciproque parce que ils
viennent d'entendre Pan, ça va très
vite. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et puis
un quart de une seconde après, le mec
était au coin et il y a il se regarde et
tout le monde est surpris. Là-dessus,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Surfie épaule
sa calache et il va littéralement, comme
on apprend dans l'infanterie, monter à
l'assaut sur les flics en leur tirant
dessus à la calche. Les flics dégainent
et repostent avec leur pistolet. La
scène est filmée. Je pense d'ailleurs
qu'on peut encore retrouver le film sur
internet. Elle est filmée par un
touriste euh qui est en face sur le
trottoir d'en face et qui ne filme pas
les faits, il filme devant lui. Mais par
contre, il y a la bande audio.
On sait ensuite par cette bande audio et
par l'enquête que l'échange de coup de
feu va durer, tenez-vous bien, 9
secondes. Faites 9 secondes. 9 secondes.
Les policiers tirent 27 cartouches dont
l'un qui va en tirer 15 à lui tout seul.
Et moi, je suis l'avocat des policiers.
celui qui tire, qui est d'ailleurs celui
qui avait pris le dispositif pour
préserver le la sécurité de ses hommes,
me dit
"Je tire, je j'ai le gars bien aligné
sur le le guidon et tout, je tire, je
tire, je tire et je et et il me dit je
suis sûr que je suis dedans comme on
dit, c'est-à-dire que je le touche mais
le gars en face continue à avancer et à
tirer et mon client me dit mais je je
finis par me dire excusez-moi mais
[__] mais mais mais mais mais mais
mais il va il va qu'est-ce qui lui
arrive ? Et finalement, au bout de 9
secondes, l'islamiste tombe. Et quand
on va aller euh le voir, on va se rendre
compte qu'il a 13 impacts. Il a pris 13
impacts de 9 mm. Tout ça pour vous. Et
des histoires comme ça, il y en a plein.
Le 9 mm, il y a plein de vidéos de la
police américaine qui sont en libre
accès sur YouTube et on se rend compte
que pour que les gens soient hors de
combat, c'est-à-dire et là je refais du
droit, pour que la menace cesse, pour
que la menace cesse, on est en légitime
défense jusqu'à ce que la menace a
cessé. Et pour que la menace cesse de
façon tangible, c'est-à-dire que l'agent
se rende compte que la menace a cessé,
il y a pas 36 solutions. Il faut que le
le danger est cessé par le fait que
l'ennemi est lâché son arme. Et pour
qu'il lâche son arme, il faut soit alors
soit vous avez un coup de bol monumental
et vous tapez le cervelé direct et là ça
dure une seconde et c'est et ça soulage
tout le monde. Mais dans la vraie vie,
ça arrive extrêmement rarement et il
faut plusieurs coups. des tirs de
sommation. Euh il lui il lui a pas fait
les coups des genre lâchez votre arme,
tir de sommation.
Non parce que là il tir il a tiré sur
ils ont tiré sur eux tout de suite.
Euh question internet, c'est c'est
joyeux he cette histoire. Euh a-t-il un
exemple concret de société plus apaisée
lorsque le port d'arme est étendu ?
Euh alors plus apaisé ? Je sais pas.
Alors, d'abord, vous avez des États
américains quand même où le le port
d'arme, le concealed carry, donc le port
d'arme discret,
aboutit à ce que sur les statistiques de
crime, on soit sur des normes qui qui
tangentent les normes européennes. Et
donc les les les pays où il y a du les
États américains où il y a du du council
carry ont un degré de criminalité qui
est qui est plus faible que celui où il
y en a pas. Ben pour une raison très
simple, hein, le criminel, il va il n'a
pas envie de s'en prendre une. Donc euh
euh dans de laadage, dans le doute,
abstiens-toi. C'est très simple. Si on
se pense que chez les gens il y a des
armes, on va avoir moins de tendance à y
aller. Voilà.
Un commerçant qui est armé pour ou
contre ?
Alors, non seulement pour, mais c'est
possible. Euh aujourd'hui, il y a une il
y a trois dispositions possibles de pour
pour porter une arme en France he
juridiquement. Et l'une de ces
l'une de ces possibilités, c'est ce
qu'on appelle le port au titre de
défense et c'est un faux ami parce qu'en
fait c'est pas défense de la personne,
c'est défense d'un lieu. Et donc euh
Jean
Benala
Jean Benala quand il était à la REM en
la République en marche, c'est le titre
qu'il avait exactement en 2016-27,
c'était attaché au lieu sans avoir le
droit de faire sortir l'arme. Et les
bijoutiers par exemple, il y a beaucoup
de bijoutiers armés. Ils ont le droit
dans le cadre de leur bijouterie de
porter l'arme pour lequelle ils ont eu
l'autorisation. Par contre, ils ont pas
le droit de la porter dehors.
Ils ont pas le droit de faire de selfie
avec, hein.
C'est enfin no comment sur l'allusion
que vous faites. Par contre, comme très
bon connaisseur des armes, je vais vous
dire qu'il y a quatre règles de sécurité
absolue et que l'une d'elles, c'est
qu'on ne vise pas ce qu'on est prêt à
détruire et que on ne sort jamais jamais
jamais jamais une arme pour pour jouer,
pour faire le mariol. Et en tout cas, on
ne pointe absolument jamais euh euh des
copains, pas des copains avec son arme.
Jamais. Mais je veux dire, c'est j'ai
même rien que de vous en parler, j'ai
une réticence musculaire à mon bras.
C'est c'est pas possible.
Est-ce que vous êtes droitier ?
Oui. Et euh
chacun l'aura vu grâce à mon lieutenant
colonel Benala, ça sonne bien ou pas ?
Non.
Alors, d'abord, moi je suis avocat d'un
des commissaires de police dans le
dossier, donc je je suis un petit peu
réticent à vous faire des des
commentaires des commentaires trop
poussés. Euh je peux juste vous dire au
d'une manière générale sur le lieutenant
colonel que c'est un grade qui est un
grade qui existe comme ça s'appelle
spécialiste. C'està-dire que vous avez
des gens qui n'ont jamais été militaires
et qui ont un c'est une équivalence qui
existe dans la gendarmerie et qui sont
spécialistes. Par exemple, quelqu'un qui
parle très bien anglais peut devenir
lieutenant colonel spécialiste avec au
fin de de de consacrer quelques jours de
réserve par an à aider le à aider le
l'étatmajor à traduire des textes ou à
faire de la de la de la
colonel dans la dans l'intelligence
économique, on peut être facilement
colonel
pour ça. C'est pas un peu pareil
euh dans l'intelligence économique
si on a une compétence particulière
qu'on est spécialisé, on a pas
C'est pas militaire l'intelligence
économique ?
Pas non mais c'est pas militaire mais
traducteur c'est pas militaire non plus.
Oui c'est ça non ? Oui on a des
compétences Oui. Quelles qu'elles soit.
Oui je suis d'accord avec vous.
D'accord. Euh autre question d'internet.
Est-il favorable à un référendum sur les
limites de la surveillance que l'on se
donne au nom de la sécurité nationale ?
euh les référ la question de sécurité,
liberté, machin, on en a parlé tout à
l'heure. J'ajoute juste que les
référendums en France, il faut faire
très attention parce que le l'histoire
montre que les gens répondent pas à la
question mais répondent à celui qui l'a
posé. Euh
donc je pense que dans le contexte
actuel, euh si j'étais l'exécutif, je
m'abstiendrai de faire un référendum. Et
après, si on avait des référendums plus
techniques comme les Suisses, il faut ça
dépendrait tellement de la question, la
façon dont la question est posée, la
votation. Ouais, ça dépend tellement de
la façon dont la question est posée.
Je vois que nous avons un candidat de
l'UPR qui est en ligne avec nous.
Faut-il un frexite pour reprendre le
contrôle des migrations ?
Alors, je pense pas parce que il y a
Gérard Colomb a dit "On est submergé
donc du coup je suis très à l'aise pour
dire la même chose. Euh et je pense que
tout seul tout seul c'est totalement
illusoire qu'on y arrive. Par contre, et
alors là, je je suis sur une ligne de
pragmatisme, mais enfin qui va pas
surprendre ceux qui nous écoutent depuis
le début, c'est que je pense moi qu'il
faut avoir,
il faut absolument empêcher que le le
l'immigration clandestine continue à
rentrer. Vous voyez ce qui rentre par
l'Espagne, vous voyez ce qui rentre par
l'Italie. Vous connaissez évidemment les
techniques des passeurs, c'est-à-dire
que dès lors que le bateau est dans les
eaux territoriales des eaux
internationales, ils appellent tout de
suite les Italiens et donc au nom du
droit de la mer et cetera, il y a les
secours qui viennent. Donc je vais moi
je suis pour la mise en place, alors
toute chose égale par ailleurs de de
méthodes extrêmement dures et ça marche
très bien en Australie qui consiste à
interdire au bateau de le passage au
bateau, à reconduire aux portes de
départ. Ça marche pas Mayotte hein.
Non non Mayotte. Oui oui on est bien
d'accord.
C'est Zaudi
hein.
Mamutzu
le comme lieu là le le connaissez un peu
Mayotte.
J'y suis jamais allé mais les gendarmes
m'en ont beaucoup parlé.
Non ça marche pas mais c'est vrai qu'à
Mayotte on a alors on commence à à
changer partiellement le le le droit du
le droit du sol à Mayotte. Mais pour
revenir, vous avez raison hein, Mayotte
est un vrai problème. Mais pour revenir
à la Méditerranée, euh je
Non, Mayot n'est pas un problème.
Bah si, Mayot,
lit, il est magnifique.
Non non, mais pardon, le le les je
contraction de pensée, l'immigration à
Mayotte est un problème.
Le ce que je veux dire c'est que moi je
suis absolument favorable au nom de là
encore d'un pragmatisme
froid, je l'assume, compte tenu de
l'ampleur des problèmes qui sont
directement indirectement liés
aujourd'hui à à l'immigration de masse
qui rue quand même quasiment toutes les
par arborescence toutes les
problématiques dont on parle depuis le
début euh et bien à faire une
interdiction totale c'est pas très
compliqué mais c'est une volonté
politique avec les bateaux
Euh vous raccompagner. Ensuite les
bateaux des passeurs vides euh rien
n'empêche de l'écouler. Je suis désolé
mais
Ouais, ça fait une économie parallèle
dans les comors. Il y a ça fait des
économies parallèles à à Madagascar. Il
y a des mecs qui font des bateaux en fib
de verre, ils se font les couilles en
or. Ça a rien changé.
On fait quoi ? On les laisse crever en
mer, on fait de l'élevage de requins, on
fait quoi ? Non non non, on fait pas Non
non, attention, je précise vide, je veux
dire. Mais il faut, il y a un mais vous
savez, il y a des il y a des haut
fonctionnaires qui ont proposé ça. Il y
a des haut fonctionnaires de
l'administration qui ont proposé ça aux
différents gouvernements depuis quelques
années, hein. C'est bah de de faire ce
que je dis, c'est-à-dire de de faire un
blocus et cetera. À chaque fois, on leur
a dit c'est à chaque fois, on leur a dit
en gros, vous avez raison mais c'est
politiquement invendable. Mais c'est
mais mais regardez euh regardez ce que
pensent les populaires. Moi je je vais
vous dire hein, je pense que si on
demandait votre internaute il y a 5
minutes nous nous proposer un
référendum, moi je vous donne mon je je
prends pas grand risque en vous disant
ce que je viens de dire parce que ça
n'arrivera pas. Mais si jamais il y
avait un référendum où on proposait au
peuple aux peuples européens de mettre
en place une politique d'interdiction
d'accès euh à au territoire européen
avec des spots euh autour de l'Europe
pour étudier euh l'asile parce qu'il est
pas question de renoncer à l'asile. Mais
aujourd'hui en droit le droit
communautaire et son application font
que des gens qui rentrent en Europe ils
y restent et s'ils font une demande
d'asile qui est rejetée, le taux de
reconduite est inférieur à 3 %. Donc en
pratique, l'axiome qui est retenu en
face, c'est "Une fois que tu es en
Europe, tu y restes." Point. Donc euh si
on faisait un référendum, la la le oui a
des mesures extrêmement dures, telles
que celles que je viens d'évoquer, euh
il serait de l'ordre de 70 % minimum.
Euh une petite parenthèse, vous venez de
vous faire fact checker.
Ah ! Le professeur John Donau de
Stanford Law School a constaté que les
États qui ont opté pour le right to
carry Lows ont connu une augmentation de
13 à 15 % des crimes violents au cours
des 10 dernières années qui ont suivi
l'adoption de c c ces lois.
Alors, je serais ravi d'en débattre avec
lui dans un autre cadre, mais après
c'est une question de définition,
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on appelle
Mais je pense alors c'est peut-être les
attaques à je confronte peut-être avec
les attaques à domicile, mais d'une
manière générale euh je suis sur cette
idée donc je regarderai, je reprendrai
mes dossiers. Je encore une fois, je
pense aussi qu'il y a une question de
définition.
Alors, don ça s'écrit D O N O H U E. OK,
ça marche.
Euh, il est 17h34, on arrive à la fin de
notre
Ouais,
on arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Des choses à rajouter ?
Merci.
C'est tout.
Bah, c'est déjà pas mal.
Je voulais juste dire merci. Vous avez
pas un sujet que vous voulez aborder
quelque chose ? Euh
non, je pense que enfin je pense que
voilà, ça fait 2 heures donc les gens
ont à peu près compris. Euh je pense
qu'on est à on on est à sur de sur une
période de 2 3 ans hein, on est à la
croisée des chemins de de de l'évolution
de l' de la France et de l'Europe. Euh
les gens qui nous regardent, quel que
soit leur âge, euh ont sont dans une
situation qui est totalement différente.
Vous faisiez allusion tout à l'heure en
disant de votre temps totalement
différente à celle qui était encore
celle de de de de nos perspectives il y
a 10 ans et je parle même pas d'avant
qui est que aujourd'hui on peut pas se
projeter. On peut pas savoir à quoi
ressemblera le monde dans 3 ans. On peut
pas savoir. Notre monde he notre monde
on peut pas savoir. Peut-être que ça va
bien tourner, peut-être que ça va très
mal tourner et peut-être que ça va être
entre les deux. Mais personne ne peut
aujourd'hui évidemment dans sa vie
personnelle, il faut continuer à
s'organiser, à travailler, à à faire à à
avancer. Mais il faut que chacun est à
l'esprit que ça va dépendre de notre
détermination, ça va dépendre de de la
capacité à avoir du courage et à un
moment, il faudra en avoir. Euh ou alors
on considère que la paix que la paix
absolue muniquoise vaut tout et et et on
subit. Mais face à la pression euh qu'on
a en face, je je pense que je pense que
les les les trois tr qu années qui
viennent vont vont être euh compliqué et
que le monde le monde des années 20
aujourd'hui, personne ne peut le
personne ne peut présentir à quoi il
ressemblera.
Une demi-parenthèse. Est-ce que vous
avez lu le comité invisible ?
Non.
Je referme la parenthèse. Donc notre
dernière question de notre émission,
c'est pas une question, c'est laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations, une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable. Shakespeare readiness is
all. Tout est dans la préparation, dans
l'anticipation.
Tibo de Montbrillard, merci.
Merci.
[Musique]